[inaudible] everybody.
This episode of the podcast is brought to you by [inaudible] Dot Com o.N n.
I.
T.
We are as human optimization website.
And what we sell it on it is strength and conditioning,
equipment,
supplements,
healthy snacks,
all different things that can help improve your body,
including as of today,
the new Werewolf legend Kettle Bell.
We have these new legend series,
kettle bells.
If you've seen the other ones before the,
uh,
the great apes,
kettlebells and the Zombie kettlebells.
We just came out with the newest ones,
the legend bells,
and it's,
it's pretty fucking awesome.
It's a 28 kilogram werewolf.
So what does that 54 pounds or something like that?
How does it work?
2.2 more than that.
60 pounds must be 60,
close to 60.
Something like that,
right?
On 16th,
isn't it?
62 pounds.
That sounds good.
Yeah,
we suck at metric system marijuana.
They tried to push that shit,
dude.
You remember the high school days?
They were like,
it's the future.
Fuck you.
It is.
We've got the bombs bitch inches,
inches,
pounds.
Go Fuck yourself kilograms.
Uh,
anyway.
Um,
the,
uh,
the new one that just came in stock is a werewolf,
the 62 pound werewolf.
And we have a bunch of other ones that are on the way.
Um,
maybe a big foot,
I'm not gonna lie to you.
It might be becoming
all the kettle bells that we have though.
The,
the,
we have regular ones,
you know,
if you're not in a fancy shit,
uh,
that,
are just standard kettlebells.
And then the,
the,
the primal bells and the legend bells,
the Zombie Bells,
all those are three d mapped.
And what that means is they're not just good looking.
They're very functional.
They're designed so that they're,
they're completely balanced out.
So when you're lifting them,
there's no weird balance points.
If you,
uh,
if you have ever worked with kettle bells before,
it's essentially like a bowling ball with a handle on it.
And it's all about using your entire body as one individual unit to promote what
they call functional fitness.
What that means is,
you know,
like if you just do bicep curls,
that's great for doing bicep curls,
but it's not going to necessarily help you run up a hill.
It's not necessarily going to help you be able to do things physically carry
things better.
Um,
what,
what I'm concerned with and the kinds of things that we sell it on,
it are all things that promote functional strength,
complete body coordination,
strength,
things that improve athleticism.
So if you're involved in a sport,
if you are doing martial arts or something along those lines,
um,
this is in my opinion,
the best strength and conditioning type workout and you could ever do,
uh,
we also sell all kinds of foods and supplements including the new warrior bar
that is a organic buffalo,
14 grams of protein,
140 calories,
super healthy for you,
no bullshit in it,
no MSG,
no soy,
no lactose,
no antibiotics or added hormones.
14 grams of protein in 140 calories with four grams of fat per serving.
Excellent for runners,
climbers,
you know,
anybody who wants a keep something that's really healthy and small packet.
Keep it with you.
You,
you can't get any better than these warrior bars.
I fucking love these things.
I,
I seriously go through a box.
I'm a week.
We also a hemp protein powder,
a the new hemp force bars,
which are excellent as well.
All this stuff's available on a.com.
It's o,
n,
I t use the Codeword Rogan and you will save 10% off any and all supplements
were also brought to you by draft kings.com drafting grap.
What's that word you're asking?
Any more coffee?
So what?
I'm going to come here after I workout at brains,
what's going on?
Why are we talking?
draftkings.com is the newest sponsor.
And if you're one of those dorks like Jamie over here who's into fantasy
football,
we were not,
I see dorks.
We'll,
I'll love my friend.
Easy.
We were in Denver and,
and Jamie was in a panic.
The kid was in a tizzy because he couldn't get online with his phone to make his
choices for his fantasy football league.
And Him and his friends there.
They're so serious about this shit that they had to reset.
You guys reset,
right?
You've reset the whole draft later and I had to miss it so you got fucked.
Oh,
the second time I got super fucked.
Okay.
They got fucked the first time and then you got fucked the second time.
Yes.
That's bullshit.
Do you use you?
You got it first.
I'm pushing for a redraft right now.
I agree with you.
I say we've promoted on the podcast,
but what he's doing is just bullshit with draftkings.com is doing draft
kings.com you can actually win money.
This is going to sound ridiculous.
One player on draftkings.com turned 11 bucks into $4,000 in one weekend.
Another guy won a hundred grand a hundred fucking grand the first time ever
playing.
Now ready for this one player won a fucking million dollars in one day playing
fantasy football.
That sounds like I'm lying to you.
I don't believe it,
but I know it's true.
It's definitely true.
I know it's true,
but I'm reading that.
I'm like,
what?
You can make a fucking million dollars in a day playing fantasy football.
It almost makes me want to play fantasy football almost,
but I can't do it.
I can't.
I can't dig that deep into the Dork drawer.
But if I could,
I would do it.
A draft,
kings.com God damn,
if you're into that kind of stuff,
man,
this is the fucking place for you.
Draft kings.com has it wired.
You can win huge cash this week.
I might do it.
You know,
we should do it once.
We should do it.
I should set up,
we got one.
Okay.
You need to help me,
you to help me.
I don't know who plays good that got good.
I would just,
I'm going to be honest with you.
I'll just go for all the black guys.
That's the biggest,
blackest guys.
This the strongest great strategy.
Is that a good move?
And I felt that'll work.
That's all they do.
Right?
And so what they do,
they seem to be better at it.
There's like white line backers that are good,
right?
One.
I'm writing this piece because of the whole John Jones racism thing.
I'm writing this whole piece about how when I was a kid,
I used to root for white guys cause it's totally true.
I used to root for Gerry Cooney.
Ray Mercer fucking cured me of that shit.
When he beat the fuck out of Tommy Morrison,
I'm like,
I'm so done.
We're only trying to root for white guys.
It just doesn't work out.
Anyway,
where was I?
draftkings.com you can win fucking big cash.
Really big cash hurry and get a free entry into the millionaire maker event
where first pray.
Oh,
this is so crazy.
The millionaire maker event first place takes home $1 million.
That's crazy.
I'm working on,
that's how you do it though.
You're going to quit,
Huh?
If you never,
I would never.
Okay,
good.
I'll give you a raise even if you win 1 million bucks.
How about that?
I'll take it head over to draft kings.com right now and enter the Promo Code
Rogan to play free to become a millionaire.
Could you imagine if you want to fucking million dollars by going to draft
kings.com right now using the Promo Code Rogan for free and you win 1 million
bucks.
Draft kings.com bigger events,
bigger winnings,
bigger millionaires.
Enter Rogan for free entry now@draftkings.com that's draft d,
a r a f t kings.com do you know how to spell kinks?
Fuck off.
Anyway,
and last but not least,
is that it?
Oh Ting we're brought to you by ting.
Ting is the official provider,
the official cell phone provider for this podcast and a,
I have a tank phone.
I have it right here.
It's the Samsung Galaxy s five and my bill just came in.
This is the first month of the official use.
My bill was 18 bucks.
That shit's ridiculous.
So ridiculous.
The average bill is mine's below the average bill cause I don't really call
anybody or just text,
but the average bill is $21 $21 for a monthly bill.
What Ting is is a cell phone provider that uses a sprint backbone so they rent
time on sprint but then they do it entirely.
There were no contracts,
no early termination fees,
no packages or bundling fees or any of that bullshit,
no overage fees,
and you only pay for what you use.
Instead of having like a fixed bill every month where it's like you know
whatever you pay,
you get a hundred minutes or 50 bucks or whatever the fuck it is.
Instead of doing that,
it's not that cheap though.
Right now.
Nobody's out shooting now,
whatever it is,
instead of having a hundred minutes.
If you had it like that and you only used 80 minutes,
they're not giving you your money back for that 20 minutes that you didn't use.
But with Ting,
you only pay for what you use.
If you use your phone call once,
I mean if you use your phone once in a month,
you're going to have the most ridiculously small bill ever.
Have you use it every day?
It'd be slightly larger,
but it'll definitely be smaller than any other provider.
You're going to use it with 98% of people would save money with Ting.
That's pretty crazy.
And again,
we're talking about the sprint backbone.
So it's just like you have a spa,
a phone on sprint,
you get the exact same coverage,
including a four g,
you know,
um,
and they have all,
if you go to Ting rogan.ting.com they have all the latest cell phones,
including I have,
which is the Samsung Galaxy s five,
which I like it a lot.
It's pretty fucking dope.
And it's waterproof.
It's warranted.
They call it water resistant.
I think that's legal ease.
And it's because there's a little tab here on the bottom.
And if you pop that tab,
I guess water can get in there and you're fucked.
But if you close that bitch up,
like it's not that hard to do,
then it's waterproof.
Yeah,
you can put it in the sink or something like,
Oh yeah,
you throw it in the pool.
It's good for like a half an hour at the bottom of the pool.
I'm not trying that,
but,
but if he did and also has a f one of those thumb,
thumb print things,
press it here in the slide that bitch up and had recognized your thumbprint.
I like it.
I love it.
The screens fucking awesome.
And finally a apple came aboard and I'm sure Tim will be carrying the uh,
the uh,
apple phones.
The new iPhone's once they have them once they get them in stock.
But like for right now you can get the Samsung,
uh,
we can get a bunch of different ones.
You can even go old school if you want.
If you're a cheap fuck,
you can get the Samsung Galaxy s two for 95 bucks and a,
I have one of those I,
that was my first tank phone to fucking,
it's good phone.
It's not a bad phone at all.
You can get an iPhone four.
If you're cheap.
Fuck,
you can get that for 137 bucks or you can get an iPhone five for 250 bucks.
Can't go wrong and it's yours.
You own it.
That's it.
There's no contracts.
Meaning when you buy a phone with most providers,
what you're doing is you're,
you're paying,
like if a phone,
like if you go to,
you know,
fill in the blank,
whatever major provider and you buy a phone,
it says the phones,
300 bucks.
It's not really 300 bucks.
It's probably six and the other 300 bucks you have to pay over the course of
your contract.
So if you don't get cell phone service in your house and you're like,
this sucks,
I want to cancel and go with another brand,
you can't do it because if you do cancel it,
you owe them 300 bucks.
It's kind of annoying and you don't think about it.
Why you do it.
You just think,
oh,
that's $300 but it's not with Tang,
they don't have any of that bullshit.
If you buy the phone,
you have it,
it's yours.
If you want to cancel,
you just cancel.
That's it.
rogan.tang.com go there.
Save yourself 25 bucks off of any of their fantastic devices.
All right,
that's it.
Tim Barnett from Solo Hunter is here.
Why fuck around Jamie,
cue the music,
the Joe Rogan experience,
try by day Joe Rogan podcast by night.
So
over the last couple of years I've really gotten into hunting.
Uh,
I went on my first hunting trip with Steve Rinella and started watching a lot of
hunting TV show.
So I've kind of always watched a lot of them.
But your show really stood out and this is a show,
uh,
you guys on the outdoor channel,
channel two,
channel after channel.
It's called Solo Hunter.
And you go out there,
you,
and,
uh,
I've seen the ones with Ramey warrant as well.
And by yourself,
just bring cameras,
go to these remote locations in,
set up the cameras and you're using your own cameras.
You're like setting up the shots while you're aiming,
like you're getting ready to shoot the animals and you're setting everything.
Like you've got like crane,
little,
little handheld things here and Gopros and
it's got to make it very difficult.
So knowing it's a pain to not just get out there and,
and you know,
hunting is difficult enough creeping up on animals.
Stalking,
getting into position is difficult enough.
But I would imagine that being your own camera man makes it,
I mean,
what's the 50 50% harder?
100% harder.
Ah,
you know,
the hunting part of it,
it's the same.
You're still hunting.
And actually it makes me a better hunter because I find that I'm a lot more a
patient and a lot more relaxed about it and more deliberate in my hunting.
So it's not just like,
oh,
I got a rifle.
Like all I got to do is get within 400 yards.
Just like,
no,
I got a rifle and I got a camera and I got this.
So I feel like I hunt better.
But the actual success rate of killing and you're getting it on film and that
kind of thing,
it's,
it's a lot harder.
Is it like,
would you say like you're like half a successful this way?
No,
I mean,
no,
I don't think it's affected my success rate on,
on actually harvest in an animal,
but it just makes it more,
it makes it more difficult to do.
And it's,
it's,
it's a,
it's a hassle.
It's not a hassle.
I mean,
it's what I do,
but it's like it's hard.
It makes it to where it's not just a hunt anymore.
It's a hunt that I'm trying to document.
And then now when you,
when you look at it and you're trying to actually produce something good that
people are going to want to watch instead of sad or whatever,
then you're putting more thought into producing it,
then you are the hunting part of it.
And then it's like,
well crap,
now I'm not a very good hunter cause I'm a good produce.
So you have this constant dilemma.
You can tell I'm already tore up about it,
but it's like you have this constant back and forth between yourself.
It's like,
screw it today.
I'm just going to hunt,
man.
I'm not going to touch a camera.
And then halfway through the day I'm like miserable because nothing's going on.
I'm like,
I don't even have anything to show for it.
Well,
it's stupid.
Turn on the cameras.
You'll have something to show for it.
So,
right.
Do you?
Um,
it's kind of,
it's a tricky way to,
to do a television show and you do all the producing yourself.
You did,
you do all the film editing on the jazz?
Yeah,
I do all the editing and that's just kind of kind of my thing for it.
And I liked,
I liked it because I can get more emotionally invested into it and I feel like
it can come out different,
but I'm not the best editor out there.
I'm just the one that happens to edit that show because I'm below budget guy.
And when I started out it was,
I mean it wasn't even,
it wasn't even ready.
It wasn't time yet,
you know?
How long have you been doing it now?
So solo hunter went to Erin October of 2010 but I had done TV since 2004 in a,
in kind of random ways in that.
But we had the guys that I was partners with,
we hired a producer that was doing all the editing and me and Jeff,
we'd be in the studio just all day and all night just hammering out with this,
with this producer.
And at the end of the day,
we weren't 100% happy with what we were getting.
So when we split up,
but I went in my own route,
I was like,
you know,
a lot of only way I'm going to do this and make money and uh,
and do it right is I got to learn to editing.
So I bought,
I mean I bought a computer and just totally self taught myself how to edit.
And I started cranking out some,
just some videos online and everything and that's Kinda how I got into it and
got more evolved.
The TV side of it.
She like final cut pro or I,
so yeah,
in fact I'm today,
I'm still using the same exact system that I bought 10 years ago.
That same exact system really change.
Just a few updates.
That's it.
Yeah.
I'm using final cut seven,
you know,
old school,
I don't know what the numbers are up to now.
It's like proactive or something to mark here,
uses Adobe or whatever.
But to me it's like the editing software in that 10 year old state is way more
powerful than my brain is to keep up with it anyway.
So it's like all I gotta do is link video together and slap some music to it.
And I got a TV show,
you know,
it's,
it's funny when you look back at computers that were,
you know,
five,
six,
seven years ago,
they were incredibly powerful and much more powerful than for w,
you know,
the applications that most people use them for the,
most people have way over powered computers.
They're just going online and clicking on links and stuff and they have these
ridiculous computers that can edit,
crunch video and do all kinds of massive calculations.
And then just never use it.
I mean,
at the end of the day,
do I have the best TV show on the network?
No.
Do I have the worst one?
Do I have one that I really like and enjoy and love?
Heck yeah.
It's my favorite,
one of my favorites to watch.
My favorite to watch Jim Shockey's uncharted,
that new show that he does,
bores the hell out of me.
Does it?
I love it for what it is.
I don't think it was intended to be a quote unquote hunting show.
No,
it's not.
It's like a cultural show.
Brantlyn is probably one of the best producers that you'll ever find.
You know what I mean?
It's,
it's extremely,
extremely well produced and uh,
I think that's good.
But I also think that a lot of producers,
especially young producers coming into the industry or are kind of kind of
falling into the game where they feel like the show has to be so well produced
to be successful.
Not doesn't it,
you go out and kill something and you bring it home.
These are hunting shows we're talking about,
you know,
their adventure shows.
They don't have to be the best produce shows and not every shot has to be on a
Jib or on a slider or you know,
of rack focus and all that kind of thing.
Capture the action and the entertainment.
And that's where a lot of these productions miss out.
But uncharted is,
is incredible from a production standpoint and from a like,
you know,
almost almost like a modern doc,
modern documentary type of field till he's,
if you haven't seen in Jim Shockey's,
this guy who's been around forever,
this real kind of legendary,
the great white hunter from,
uh,
from a BC,
from British Columbia,
and he goes all over the world.
Like,
I mean,
literally all over the world click these really remote places in Pakistan.
He's the man to hunt goats.
You've never heard of this weird fucking funky look and goats.
And the thing of it is,
is like,
you know,
he's got the,
he's got the life to back it up and you look back beyond television before he
started doing television.
The man lived that lifestyle.
Like he had it.
I mean,
he's one of the true,
true people would actually grew up in a hunting environment in not just hunting,
but harsh,
harsh country,
you know,
doing it the right way and,
and building an outfitting business.
And it just happened to evolve at a television career here.
Have you ever watched him on real tree when he would do the little segment?
You know,
in the,
in the middle?
I think it was real tree.
I don't know.
That's a long time ago,
but he's really,
he's really,
you know,
deserved and earned where he's at and put himself there.
Yeah.
He's coming on and,
uh,
sometime in November we're working it out now,
but he,
um,
he,
he does these shows that are almost like their documentaries on the culture that
he's going to,
as much as it is about the hunting,
the people he can deal.
It delves in a lot to the people I liked and,
uh,
the way they captured,
you know,
just like some of those villages and the way people live,
I mean,
it's,
it's incredible.
It really brings a reality.
It's almost like a nat geo type of a feel to it.
Yeah.
I'm not interested in doing that though.
No.
The hard thing that I would like to see,
and I don't think it could ever happen,
but like can you imagine going into some of those places with somebody to
actually experiencing it and that's the thing that the cameras can't show you.
They can't show you the actual experience because inevitably the guy behind the
camera or the producer is wanting to bring drama into it.
They're wanting to bring something out of what's going to captivate the viewer
while I'm going to do this and this,
and he may use a shot that the kid was doing dishes or something and use it in a
scene where where something dramatic happened.
The kids crying because he was cutting onions or something.
I mean,
producers have a way of twisting things to make it look more,
more glorified and more glamorous than it might've actually been.
Well,
that's one of the things about hunting shows that hasn't really,
it hasn't happened where it has with reality TV.
A lot of these reality TV shows are the furthest thing from reality that you
could ever imagine.
Everything is completely scripted.
It's calculated.
Every event's calculated from the beginning to the end there.
These shows are just,
they're just drama shows like bullshit,
fake fiction,
drama shows that they don't have unnecessary,
they don't have a script,
but they have an objective.
Exactly like you and I are going,
we're going to go by Mexican food and you're like,
I fucking hate,
but I hate Mexican food and we have a conversation and then you know,
you go,
we go to another place.
Like how about this place,
dude,
I fucking hate Mexican food.
And then come on man.
And like at the end we wind up at a Taco bell and you're like,
hey,
this isn't bad.
Like that's a fucking reality show scenario.
The best reality show would be film from a drone and the people wouldn't even
actually know what it was there.
That would be the ultimately reality show.
Yeah.
Well,
I think they kind of try to do that with like a big brother type scenario,
but everything changes once people know they're being filmed out.
Exactly.
You know,
and it's just,
they're just bad shows.
Most of them are just really bad shows.
Whereas like one of the things I like about your show and Rinella show and a lot
of these hunting shows is they're willing to show failure too,
which is a big part of hunting.
Oh,
it's,
yeah.
It's a majority of hunting.
Yeah.
I mean you're,
you're doing something that's very difficult to do.
You are going into a natural habitat that this animal lives in there trying to
defy.
All of us has all of its natural instincts,
that sense of smell.
It's incredible hearing all these different evolved instincts that they have to
keep them alive and you're trying to creep up on them and you're filming the
whole thing.
Yeah.
Well and I think a lot what a lot of people may not look at,
you know,
and I get it sometimes it's just like everything's wrapped around that,
that moment of impact,
that kill,
you know,
and especially when you're filming it by yourself,
it's really hard to get that moment of impact in that moment of kill on there.
But that's like one moment,
you know,
and it's,
and it's like the most morbid of the entire,
the entire episode or the entire five week long journey after that animal.
But everybody focuses on that moment and it's like,
no,
you know,
there's,
there's 10 days of planning and preparation and hunting and actual stuff going
on outside of that one little kill.
How did you get the idea to do this show?
But why didn't you try to do a show?
Did you ever try to do a show with a camera man that comes with it?
I did.
So I partnered with a guy in 2000 late 2004 so it was really kind of 2005 and we
produced a show on,
this was one of the first shows on sportsman channel way back then.
And that shows running today.
You know,
it's continuing on and he's branched off and he's got a couple of shows that
he's doing.
But when I left that shows that,
um,
it's buck ventures,
ventures is where I started and now he's got major league bow hunter and he's
partnered with chipper Jones and that,
you know,
somebody with a lot deeper pockets than I have for sure.
Chipper Jones was a baseball player,
right?
Yeah.
I think that's what,
that's helped me pull,
pull this thing up to your face.
So yeah,
sorry.
Volume as be there.
These are different tweaky microphones.
So,
so,
you know,
I moved out to Oklahoma.
I mean,
I,
when I did that,
when I do things I like go ballsy in.
It's,
it's everything.
And so I sold my home,
moved.
My wife had a one,
my boy was one year old at the time and we moved to Oklahoma.
We just live just outside of Oklahoma City and Edmond and,
uh,
just partnered up and started the show.
Loved it.
And um,
he,
you know,
everything was going to go with,
it was 100% white tail,
but it really wasn't my thing.
You know,
I'm,
I grew up in central Idaho in the middle of nowhere.
And for me to transition my hunting style and what I grew up with to focus just
strictly on Whitetail,
just didn't,
didn't fit.
What was your hunting style?
I grew up shoot where I grew up in central Idaho,
the nearest Walmarts 70 miles away.
I mean the population one oh one,
you know,
I mean it's,
it's a small farming town in central Idaho.
It's called the lost river valley.
Um,
I grew up right in more,
went to school in Mackey and Arco and,
and uh,
so that,
that lifestyle and growing up on a farm was rugged just in and of itself.
And so I don't know any,
anything,
any different.
And I know,
you know,
I can go out the back door and I can be up on the mountains and just go forever.
I mean,
you could go until,
till forever.
Tell Canada if you want it to.
But it's so you used to like going out and hiking,
going after these animals,
stalking them,
mountains,
western hunting.
You know where it's,
you've got elk,
you've got deer,
bear,
mountain lions.
I mean you've got everything.
The whole Western hunting,
hunting whitetail is completely different.
And one,
a white tail deer might live in just a few square miles.
It's entire life,
you know,
and you're hunting farmland predominantly or river bottoms.
And so you're really,
you know,
that's,
that's the most widely hunted game animal that there is.
But it's like,
it's almost like a farm out of venture.
The adventure starts and ends right here,
you know,
within within 200 acres or whatever.
When I go on a hunt for elk,
the adventure,
there's,
there's miles,
you know,
hundreds of miles that,
that a person could go on and the West.
And when you get up on some of these peaks and you,
you may have experienced on some of the stuff in Alaska,
but like you get up there and it's like,
Gosh,
Dang,
there's a lot here.
You know?
Yeah.
I mean there's so much country and there's no limitation to how far you can go
and what you do.
So that's,
that's when I say my style,
that's my style,
getting out remote.
And,
uh,
if that's way more fascinating to me to be in like completely wild environments
like that.
Like you said,
standing on a peak looking out in Alaska and what you're seeing is just mountain
range is just hill after hill after hill and valleys and just,
it's looks endless.
It looks endless and there's no one out there and you're looking straight ahead.
You're not seeing any fucking people.
They're seeing trees and there's some animals out there.
Go find them.
Yeah.
And that's,
that's how I grew up.
I mean,
I would go out a lot of times during school and I'd just go up,
sleep on the mountain,
come back to chores,
milk cows,
go to school,
you know,
go to football practice,
go home,
do chores,
go up on the mountain,
sleep on the mountain,
come back home.
I mean,
that was kind of how,
how my brothers and I grew up and
it's just,
I mean I just have a yearning for the wild.
I mean there,
there are some of the coolest experiences that I've had in life have been when
I'm by myself and go and do something just so totally random that,
that,
that nobody else would really even think about.
I say Shit,
I sit and say nobody.
But it's like,
you know,
in college I'd drive home two hours to my folks' house,
then I drive another hour up to the canyon.
By the time I get to the trail head,
it's 11 o'clock at night,
hike in for three or four hours,
find somewhere,
sleep,
get up on top of the mountain.
And I'm sitting there as,
as the sun's coming up and three wolverines come up,
you know,
and circle the lake and it's like back then,
in the,
in the 90s there weren't wolverines in Idaho.
There weren't supposed to be anyway.
I mean I was one of the very first or very few to actually see wild wolverines
in Idaho.
And it's like,
had I not been there by myself experiencing that in that canyon,
you know,
if there's other people or other things,
those wolverines might not have been as comfortable,
you know,
but because I was there by myself and I'm the only one there looking down over
it,
I had that experience.
And there's,
there's a lot of opportunities like that that
when you have someone else there,
you're focused on the group.
You know,
when you're focused on your conversations,
your buddies,
your friends and everything,
you're not,
you're not really tuned in to what's around you.
You're not tuned in to your surroundings.
And so there's certain things that I think you miss out on when you've got other
people there.
And it's not that I don't enjoy that sometimes,
but I feel like when I'm there,
like there's a connection,
you know,
there's a connection to the land,
there's a connection to the environment and uh,
you know,
he could bring all of it into if,
if you're,
if you're a Hippie,
you know,
tree hugger,
Voodoo type person,
you can bring in the nature and the gods and all that kind of stuff into the
whole element.
But that really and truly is,
is what it is,
is you're out there with no one but yourself and God and his creation.
I mean that's it.
It's all surrounding you.
Yeah.
And being like that deep in nature where you're actually a part of it because
you're not,
you're not talking to anyone.
So there's no,
there's no conversations going on in your conversations there just with myself.
But you know what I'm saying?
It's like you don't,
there's nothing,
no anchor that brings you back to civilization.
You just seeing wild shit.
You're just seeing wild life.
You're seeing animals that would exist that way regardless of whether or not you
were there or not.
And the sad part about it is,
is the more the older I get and the more I live in the city and the more the
more likely falls and gets busy and hectic.
I mean right now,
right now it's just seems like it's a train ride just straight up and things
are,
things happening are happening fast.
It's just like this opportunity here.
The more more than those things happen,
it's like the more desensitized I come to the natural experience.
And so when I'm out there I find myself checking where's my phone?
You know,
I wonder what emails I've got.
I wonder who's called.
And that really sucks because I'm desensitized to the nature of man,
you know,
to what I grew up as,
and that kind of thing.
And that's,
it's good in a way,
but it's also bad.
And so I like have taken the opportunity to just like,
you know,
this week I was supposed to be up hunting in Idaho,
but I had too much work to do.
I had projects I had to had to get done and it worked out great because it freed
up our time where you and I could get together.
But I know that Sunday,
you know,
as soon as I get out of church,
I'm hauling butt up to Idaho and I'm going to start elk hunting for a week.
So I'm going to have that,
you know,
eight to 10 days of solace to really get back into it.
But then at the end of that trip,
it's going to be like I've got nine hours to drive home and think about getting
back into the daily life,
you know,
to regular,
regular world,
regular world.
Um,
do,
do you have a regular job outside of this?
This is,
people think that I,
that I hunt for a living or that it's all about the hunting and the show and the
hunting is like 10% of my life,
you know,
outside of that I run my business,
I got products just like you do and,
and I'm trying to grow,
grow the business space.
And this this year I kind of took it upon myself that this is the year I wanted
to grow my business.
You know,
I had the TV show established,
I had,
you know,
making a good living and everything,
but this is the year that I wanted to take it another step and actually make,
create a business of it.
That's where I brought on mark and we started producing another show on
sportsman channel called off grid hunter and experimenting with that.
And now it's like,
you know,
I've got two other sponsors that have come to me and said,
hey,
you know,
you're doing a good job with the productions.
We've been thinking about x,
y and Z.
Would you be interested in producing,
producing our shows for us and doing different things.
So I'm now branching and trying to grow the production side of it as well as
solidify the brand of Solo.
We do a good,
you do a really good job,
uh,
producing the show yourself the way it's edited.
It's interesting.
It's not just,
you know,
here's a video camera that I turned on when I walked up to the top of the hill,
like Blair witch style.
Like,
you know,
you cut in music and sound effects and there's a lot of close ups and I mean,
not Remy calls with the Gopro show,
he's like,
we're not the go pro show anymore.
That's awesome.
Yeah,
you definitely,
uh,
edit things really well.
And,
and that,
that's a,
that's a big part of watching any kind of a show to draw people in.
But in that show in particular,
you're,
you're telling a story and your story is,
you know,
whatever animal you're chasing after,
wherever you're going,
you know,
you're entering into that environment and then you kind of like,
you're,
you're explaining your thoughts along the way.
Like one of them I really liked was you alone.
Um,
you were Moose hunting in Alaska
and,
uh,
you know,
you were,
you,
you know,
stuck in the tent and it was raining outside.
I see.
And I had a guy with,
I mean,
people need to know,
I had a guy with me and I said that right on the episode there was another guy
that had the tag,
but I mean you're out there.
You're out there in the middle of nowhere.
Yeah.
And because you're out there like that,
because you're in this like intense,
wild environment,
you know,
you get to,
when you're,
when you're talking about and when you're,
you know,
expressing yourself to the camera,
you're getting this kind of insight of what it's like to actually be there.
And for a lot of people,
that's the closest we're ever going to come to being out in there in the wild
Bush of Alaska,
chasing after a move.
So it makes it,
it's,
there's like the solitude comes across on camera and it's a,
it's an interesting element that you don't get an a lot of these shows because a
lot of these shows,
it's an expedition.
You got a couple camera man's,
you've got a guide,
you get to hunter's got all these people there,
they got a fucking the ATV,
everybody's going out into the woods together.
It's a,
it's a journey,
you know,
but the solitude of you being alone in these remote environments and you know,
quite honestly dangerous environments,
especially like the Alaska one,
cause there was bears out there at grizzlies,
you're packing a pistol when you go to take a shit,
you know,
it's,
it's ironic that,
you know,
the,
the worst,
the voice,
most hair raising experiences I've had have not even been Alaska,
you know,
it's been closer to home and that kind of thing.
I mean,
yeah,
in Alaska I got charged by a black bear.
I mean it was,
was it a female?
It had to have been because what happened is,
was we got off the boat to set up to start call for a Moose and uh,
doing some moose calling.
And I was like,
and it was raining real hard.
And I'm like,
you know what,
I got to go back and get my camera just in case something happens.
Or I hadn't had to go back and get something.
I don't remember what it was.
So I walked back to the boat and as I'm walking back,
I hear some noise behind me.
And as I turned,
this bears just coming.
I mean,
it's booking,
hauling it just as fast as it could run.
And all I did was just just wheel.
The camera just yelled bear,
bear's loud as I could.
And the thing just skidded,
stopped and took off.
And as it turned around,
I mean,
I thought I saw another one in the back.
So that's the only thing that,
that,
I mean,
it's the only thing that could have been,
was a bear hunting,
which isn't gonna happen.
A bear's skin,
whatever.
So it had to been a sow with some cubs or something on that.
Yeah,
I mean,
really at that instant you're relying on luck,
you know,
you're relying on that bear to stop and turn around because all I had to at that
time to protect myself was my voice.
You know,
by the time I would've got to my gun,
the bear would have been on me and you know,
bears bite.
And so things would have been pretty bad for,
for a little while had that bear not turned around.
And you were by yourself?
No,
I,
that was what it was there.
Ted was,
um,
yeah,
he was right in the,
in the,
in the general area because we were both hunting moose together.
Have you ever been out there by herself and had a situation come up where you're
like,
fuck,
I might,
I might not be able to get outta here,
like be an injured or you know,
fuck your knee up or anything like that?
Jacked up my knee pretty good.
And uh,
in New Zealand when I was,
when I was,
went to New Zealand there,
helped with Remi,
um,
I had just killed my tar and was coming off the mountain and I mean I wasn't
very far from the bottom,
but I had stepped in this fern or something and just Jack my knee and I remember
falling and I kind of blacked out there for a minute.
And as I'm laying there,
I'm thinking just,
I'm just like,
please don't,
don't blow my knee out,
you know?
And I just laid there for like 30 40 minutes until kind of the throbbing and the
pain kind of went away and then I was able to get up and kind of walk it off.
But that's,
that's one it gets,
you know,
that's probably one,
it's the most dangerous is when you're hauling,
you know,
a hundred plus pounds on your back and you're coming down rough country,
because I'm not going to go back up there and pack my camp out.
So you're going to load as much weight as you can on your bag in his stoop.
Is it,
something could happen in any time,
you know?
I mean,
the guy could step and roll his ankle at anytime,
you know?
It's just kind of,
by us being out there alone,
it makes it that much more dangerous,
I guess.
Stupid really.
People who have never gone hiking in these remote areas and the,
you know,
like,
especially when you're going after these mountain animals,
whether it's elk or something like that,
they don't,
they probably don't understand how treacherous some of the terrain is.
And you add into that the fact that you've got a hundred pounds of meat packed
onto your back and you probably gonna have to do it several times,
especially with an elk.
Yeah.
I laughed at my buddy.
He killed a deer last week and he's posting these pictures on Instagram of the
blisters on his feet and everything.
He's like,
come on my third trip back in to get my dear.
And I'm like hell,
if that man just cut the thing up and put it all on your bag and come out once,
you know,
don't,
how big was the deer?
Uh,
you know,
a bone down,
a boned out deer is going to be 90 pounds,
you know,
90 to 100 pounds is all got your camera gear or you got your camping gear and
that kind of stuff too.
So that's where a deer,
you know,
deer is the one trip,
one trip or for a guy.
Yeah.
I've talked to people that like,
um,
Rinella.
His brother fucked his backup essentially for life.
We're trying to haul out Mousse and now he has pack llamas lamas that he brings
with him.
And my brother tried llamas for awhile now.
I think he's got to go.
No,
I think he got a horse now.
He had goats too.
It was like,
then I can just,
Rinella has the,
his,
his brother has these llamas and they put them in a van and like the llamas,
like,
they fucking piss in the van,
the disgusting animals.
But they're just hardy is shit.
The,
you know,
he lives in Montana and he's got them out there in Montana.
They just,
he just tied to a tree and leave them there and they just,
it's freezing fucking cold out.
They just stand there.
They don't give a shit.
Oh,
they probably,
they do.
They just get to say anything about it.
They probably,
yeah,
but they're super durable.
Yeah.
And um,
the idea is you just got to make sure that you pack them evenly.
You know,
you can't have like 70 pounds off to the right and you know,
and a hundred pounds off to the left.
It has to be totally balanced out.
But once it's balanced out,
those fuckers can just go.
Yeah.
We grew up hunting with the horses,
horses and mules mostly,
you know,
so I mean it's,
it's nice to have that ability to pack,
pack camp in and pack all the way.
And I've thought about doing,
you know,
a pack trip solo,
a solo hunting pack trip.
But that's,
I mean you're bringing in a whole other element.
You bring it in an that you can't control,
you can't control their moods or whatever.
I mean,
it's just that one more,
one more thing that could go wrong.
I mean all it takes is the horse to kick you in the side of the head and you're
done.
Or you know,
you horse kicks you in the knee or a horse takes a fall or any of those kinds of
things and that's,
you know,
it can mess it up in a hurry.
So I've always,
I've just,
lately I've just got to the point where I just want to throw crap in my backpack
and go,
yeah,
because I can control me.
You know,
I know where my brain is going to be and I know where I'm stepping.
But all that horse has to do is take,
take one wrong step and eh,
yeah,
it's,
odds are it's not going to happen.
But I've had,
I've had a friend that was killed on a horse,
you know,
really what happened.
He was on a pack trip and I remember I was,
I was working at the carpet store and when I was,
when I was a kid and uh,
I was like,
John,
why don't you stay here?
I got this job I need you to do.
And he was a carpet installer and I was one of the salesman.
I'm like,
I got this job that I want you to,
that I need you to do.
He's like,
nope man,
I'm going on this pack trip.
I'm like,
come on,
it's only a two day job.
He's all no.
And I remember him vividly saying,
he's like,
life's too short.
He said,
I'm,
I've,
I promised myself no matter what,
the money is not going to get in the way and I'm going to live my life.
And that on that very trip,
his horse,
something spooked his horse and it came over on top of him,
on the Saddle Horn,
ruptured his spleen.
And uh,
he went into the hospital.
When they got back,
he went into the hospital like 220 pounds the next time I,
you know,
when he got out of the hospital,
he was like 160 pounds or something.
And it wasn't just a couple of months later that he died from that because he
had given his kidney to his son.
And so his kidney and spleen and everything were,
were jacked up and he lost his life.
You know,
from that event that can happen.
My brother,
you know,
a couple of years ago,
horse came over on the top of him,
crushed his pelvis.
Oh,
chief happens when you got wild.
When you've got animals,
the only stuff can happen,
you know.
Yeah.
I have a friends that ride horses.
They like,
uh,
my friend's wife actually,
she,
she jumps horses.
They,
they go to these fucking rings and they,
they,
they get their horses to jump over logs and shit.
And I'm like,
what are you doing?
Like why is that exciting?
Like what's going on there?
That's got to be that again,
I guess,
but we used to see,
we used to have,
my brothers and I,
we have the reputation of breaking horses so people would bring the wild
mustangs that they'd catch off the desert and stuff,
which I know now living in Nevada,
they're not that wild,
but they'd bring us these horses that they had adopt,
thinking that they would make them as kids horses or something and we'd have to
break these horses.
How do you catch them?
I don't know how they caught him.
I Dunno.
They just bring them to us in a trailer and we smack them around a little bit
and break them.
Can you break a wild horse or real wild horse?
We had all,
I mean we only had one that we really couldn't break.
They were that we didn't rake is what he'd do eat it.
No,
I,
I can't even remember what happened to that.
One of them.
The guy took back and it ended up getting away and they had to,
they ended up shooting it,
you know,
somewhere cause it got on,
got out and got on wild land ended up shooting that one.
Why they shoot it because it got on wild plant.
I don't think they could catch it.
They couldn't catch it for a while.
They tried to,
what they tried to do is shoot it in neck and hit that
tendon.
So with horses,
a lot of times like western reining horses and stuff,
a lot of times they'll go in and snip a tenant in their neck to get them to keep
their head level.
Cause it's,
I guess it's better for though the horse reins better and acts better than that
and it's not going to flip his head up and flail its head.
So they'll flip this tenant.
So this horse,
so the,
the sharp shooter went in trying to shoot this horse and the tenant in the back
of the neck to kind of just break him down so they could catch this horse.
Cause there was a big,
uh,
black and white Tevino stallion that they wanted to catch.
And they,
I think he just kind of missed and,
and killed it.
What the fuck?
Little bit of a kind of a sharp shooter does he think he is.
I don't really should have hired me a moving horse and you're going to shoot it
in a perfect spot on that.
I can't imagine shooting a horse anyway.
That's why when I see these guys going to Africa and shootin zebras and stuff,
I mean,
I grew up on a farm.
I have such a love and a passion for animals that I can't imagine.
I can't imagine that.
Well,
we were,
we were talking about that before the show that it's a weird thing for people to
hear when someone says they're a hunter,
but they love animals.
You know,
like I got this tweet the other day where this woman,
uh,
she was,
someone tweeted me something and she's tweeted,
why would you talk to him?
He kills bear for fun and you know that,
no,
I don't kill.
I've killed one bear wasn't for fun.
I eat it.
But did you have fun?
I did.
I enjoyed it.
It was,
I mean I guess I kind of killed a bear for fun.
Right?
Like I was a part of it.
There's remorse.
Well bears are pretty fucking cool.
They're interesting.
And uh,
you know,
I went with,
uh,
Cameron Hanes.
We're bow hunting in a Alberta and if you've never been up there,
first of all,
they have to kill bears up there.
There's all a lot of fucking bears up there.
They estimate between three and eight per square mile.
And uh,
when you get up there,
you realize that's true.
Cause like when you're sitting and you're waiting,
they all of a sudden within an hour or so,
they just start showing up.
One,
two,
three.
I mean we,
we saw as many,
six,
seven barrels at a time.
It's fucking crazy.
And the cannibalizing each other left and right.
They're eating cubs.
You have to kill the minerals themselves,
diseases and all kinds of stuff.
If they overpopulated.
Yeah.
And they are overpopulated up there.
You have to kill the Boers if you don't kill the Boers,
they just feast on babies.
You know,
and it's,
it's just a numbers thing.
They don't have anything to kill them.
Nothing kills them.
So if humans don't kill them,
then their populations get out of control.
They get run into starvation issues.
Uh,
there's all sorts of things that happen and they taste good.
You know,
and people are fucking weird,
man.
This,
this whole hunting thing has really exposed me to a lot of very strange
hypocrisy is that people just accept.
And one of them is this fucking guy came up to me at the airport wearing leather
shoes and he goes,
man,
I was really disappointed to find out that you killed a bear.
I go,
dude,
you're wearing fucking leather shoes.
Do Desert.
Those are leather.
I go,
do you eat meat?
He goes,
killed a cow for that.
Exactly.
He goes,
I do eat me.
But I just think bears are different.
I go different.
How?
Because they're not in your neighborhood.
Like what are you talking about?
It's an animal.
Do you understand that anything that a hunter kills lives an infinitely better
life than anything you're buying at Mcdonald's than anything you're wearing on
your clothes?
And he and his shoes and he leather and he belt that you have those animals
lived lives of unimaginable suffering.
For the most part,
those domesticated animals that are done that they're used for,
you know,
whatever it's for clothing or for,
leather goods or couches or shit like that.
Those fucking things live in pens and their,
their lives from birth to death or just for utility.
They're just,
they serve a purpose.
They're there.
There are a commodity.
When you're hunting,
you're taking an animal that lives in an entirely natural life.
You dip into that natural world,
harvest that animal,
pull it out,
and in my opinion,
that's infinitely better,
infinitely better in every way.
First of all,
the animal,
they're not going to live forever.
It's not like,
you know,
you're taking away an animal that was going to cure cancer if he kept it alive.
You know that animal was on its way to fucking building a rocket to go to the
moon and you stepped in and shot it.
Now they're fucking bears,
man.
There bears,
they're eating each other's cubs and it's really good meat and it's good for
you.
And the the,
the fact that people have a problem with hunters,
but they don't have a problem with passing by every restaurant you drive down
the street,
every restaurant is filled with meat.
Every one of them,
every supermarket filled with meat.
All these people you drive,
half of them are driving cars with leather seats.
Half of them are wearing leather shoes,
probably more than half.
But yet people have a problem with hunting.
And it's this weird thing because they don't see the death of the animal,
the cause,
their cheeseburger.
Because society is structured in a way that you can just without participating
in the animal's death at all,
you can reap the benefits of it by just giving a little piece of paper and
getting a cheeseburger.
And that's your connection to it.
You can eliminate some of yourself from some of the guilt because you didn't
kill it,
you know,
and you didn't see it get killed.
So therefore it didn't happen.
Yeah.
And people that eat meat have sent this to me and I'm like,
man,
you got to rearrange the way you think you should expose you.
I'm I,
I've told several people that have a problem with it that eat meat.
I'm like,
you should expose yourself to the death of an animal just to decide whether or
not you want to continue eating meat.
Because that was a concern when I went hunting for the first time,
like I had been fishing my whole life,
so I've killed things before and eating them,
but I've never killed an animal.
I was like,
man,
a deer is a big,
beautiful animal.
I mean,
that's going to freak me out.
Maybe I'm not going to like it.
Maybe I'll be a vegetarian.
After that.
I was like,
I was really wondering what it was going to be like.
The exact opposite happened didn't bother me at all.
I mean,
I thought it was great.
I mean it was,
there was a moment of sadness at this animal died,
but the food was delicious.
The meat was delicious.
The,
the,
the experience was exhilarating.
It was exciting.
It was fun.
It was wild.
It was enriching and it's the,
the healthiest meat you can get.
And I think the most ethical way acquire it.
You,
you're responsible for what you're eating.
And there's something super satisfying about that.
Whenever I,
I'm not at all the time,
but a lot of times when I,
uh,
I tweet photos of like wild game that I cook and when I'm like out there and I'm
grilling something that I killed and I chopped up and I'm putting it on the
grill and then I'm eating it.
Like it's just such a different experience.
Like the,
the feeling of it is so much better than just getting a steak from the grocery
store,
throwing it on the grill and eating it.
There's nothing there with that pound for pound,
it's,
it's a hell of a lot more expensive.
But that's not,
you know,
that's not what it's,
that's not what it's about.
And it's one of those things where it's like super,
super hard to explain to people when they're like,
well,
why do you want,
and even my wife,
you know,
she's,
she's not into hunting.
She never wants to be,
she doesn't understand how I can love animals so much and yet go out and kill
them and all that.
But it's one of those things that there's so many different facets as you can go
down.
While they were doing it for food,
we're doing it for this,
we're doing it for a population in general.
We're doing it for,
you know,
whatever,
for sports,
which I don't,
I don't look at hunting as a sport per se,
but there's a lot of different things,
elements that you can bring into it to explain to somebody.
And at the end of the day,
I looked at it,
I'm like,
I don't know why I do.
I'm just,
I'm a man.
You know,
I'm like,
I posted a picture of the other day on,
on Instagram.
That's like a lot of these hunting groups classify themselves as predators or as
you know,
addicts or junkies or you know,
I'm an Antler junkier or I'm this or I'm of that.
And it's like I'm a man,
you know,
God put man on this earth to till and to take care of it.
And he gave us sustenance and he gave us an ability to sustain not only
ourselves,
but to grow population.
You know,
that's what,
that's what Adam and eve were the were there if you're a religious person or
whatever,
but if you really believe Adam and eve,
everybody came from,
which is pretty fucking ridiculous.
So I just happened to be a believer in Ebony.
But anyway,
do you believe that there was two people and then everybody came from those two
people in a way?
Yeah.
Really.
I think there's,
I think that,
I definitely think that there's a lot to specific religions that are out there,
that there's pieces there that,
you know,
if you follow the Bible word for word for what it says,
like literally there's a lot of stuff that's,
there's no way.
I mean,
it's like,
no,
those are probably made up stores where,
but there's other things that I,
you know,
I'm a religious person and I believe in God and,
and,
uh,
I think there's a lot of things that people have twisted.
No doubt,
no doubt.
But,
but I'm a believer there's something to all religions that um,
I think there's like,
there's some universal truths and there's universal truths about treating people
certain ways and there's universal truths about seeking the good in life and you
know,
looking out for your brothers and sisters.
And I think all of that came from understanding that people developed over time,
wisdom that people developed over time.
And then this,
this is connecting to what is universally good about the world life with few
exceptions,
people generally,
and there's,
there are exceptions that people generally want to do good.
People generally want to be happy,
you know,
they generally understand consequence,
they understand right and wrong.
There are exceptions,
you know,
just don't understand it.
That again,
and then there's people that have callous themselves one way or the other.
Either they toe the line a hundred percent religious and everything is literal
or they go the other direction.
Yeah.
The problem with the literal translations that the,
that wasn't English,
you know,
I mean,
we were,
we still there,
they're still working on the Dead Sea Scrolls,
which is the oldest version of the Bible,
which is an Aramaic and it's on animal skins.
And they have to,
they literally have to do DNA analysis on the animal skins to make sure that
when they line up the pieces that trying to piece them all together,
that it's the right animal.
Like,
like the way they do the,
the Dead Sea Scrolls.
Have you ever paid attention to it?
I know I'm one of those is like,
I dunno,
it's like,
I don't know,
some of those things are so hard to even get into,
but if you want to be a religious person,
that's the source of it.
That's the source of almost all biblical stories is the Dead Sea Scrolls,
you know?
And um,
what's,
what's really unique about it is that it was found in Qumran,
I think in the 1940s.
They found these,
um,
these clay pots and inside these clay pots were essentially these animal skins
that have been wrapped up.
And you know these,
these cylinders and these like wrapped up in roles and they had to unravel them
and a lot of them were broken up.
And so the broken up ones,
the way they do the DNA test that they do a DNA test.
So they say,
okay,
well all animal,
all of the pieces from this animal we'll put over here,
all the pieces from that animal,
we're assuming that's a different piece of skin.
We'll put that over here.
And then there have to like try to piece it together like this ancient puzzle.
Then they have to take Aramaic and translate it into English.
And that's even older than the ancient Hebrew version of the Bible.
And the ancient Hebrew book.
The weirdest thing about the ancient Hebrew version is that apparently ancient
Hebrew didn't have numbers.
So letters were also numbers.
So the letter a was also the number one.
And like if I said Tim Burnett,
your,
there's numbers to your name that like it also,
it counts in the trends,
not to translation,
but what the meaning of the word,
like the word love and the word God have the same numerical value in ancient
Hebrew,
and this is on purpose.
It's like things have like value and the sentences have like a numerical value
to them that aren't our brains the way we think,
the way we talk,
because we have numbers separate from words.
I don't think we totally grasp what a lot of the meaning of a lot of the
sentences were.
Then on top of that,
like a lot of those words in ancient Hebrew,
there's something like 25% of them,
they still don't even know what the fuck it was.
There's a massive amount of interpretation that they have to figure out.
Then they take that and take it from there and translated to Greek into Latin,
and then from that to English.
So when you're reading about Adam and eve,
who the fuck knows what the original meaning was?
What were they trying to say?
The original human beings that God created or that the universe bestowed upon
the earth.
What,
what was that?
what do they do?
They really mean that it was just two people.
It's so hard to tell.
And when you add in all the other fuckery,
uh,
the ones where you know that somebody had a grip on it.
Somebody we know about Constantine and the bishops and how they,
they rewrote the,
the new testament and they left out a bunch of shit.
Like they had,
they chose what was going to be in the Bible are not bunch of people chose what
was going to be the word of God.
People that had no contact with God.
It's not like God came down and he gave him a fucking to do lists,
like get all this shit done and then I'll,
I'll double check your work and then I'll be back.
Now there was,
they decided.
So I'm not opposed to the concept of God and I'm,
I'm not an anti religious person at all.
Um,
I think religion is not a lot of good.
I think religion is a good foundation for a lot of people to develop morals and
ethics and I just,
whenever anybody wants to talk about like literal translations of stuff,
I'm like,
and I always want to know like how much did you look into it?
Like how when you say literal translation,
like did you,
did you go to the actual source of those stories because you got to go to
fucking the epic of Gilgamesh.
If you want to really know the Noah's Ark Story,
that's the original version of it.
It's 6,000 years old.
I mean it's,
it's,
it's written with these little lines and shit like on clay tablets.
Like that's the oldest version of that story.
Probably based on some real shit that happened probably based on real floods.
Yeah.
My brother,
he just,
what he was telling me the other day,
he watched that Noah movie,
how would this terrible,
he was like,
man,
that was the worst.
That wasn't even close.
But then he's like,
well,
there were giants in the Bible,
so maybe,
maybe I haven't seen the movie so I don't have a clue.
But he's like,
yeah,
it was so weird and everything.
But yeah,
it's,
the problem is people are full of shit.
All I know is I guarantee that if there was a,
that Noah,
he probably found a chicken and,
and it,
he probably ended up eating at one sometime and he's like,
yeah,
that tastes good.
You know,
I'm gonna eat chicken and I'm going to raise the chickens and then there's going
to be more chickens.
And then he's like,
well,
if a chicken tastes good then this sheep over here's got to taste good.
You know?
And so I just continued on,
well,
how the fuck did all the animals get to them?
That's the biggest one.
They have to walk there from all over the earth,
the now road.
How convenient.
That's one thing that's kind of cool about your podcast is the ones that I
listened to and everything.
It's like,
what I like about you is when you bring in different coasts in different guests,
a lot of them have completely opposite backgrounds and what I have and probably
from what you have to,
but I like that you're fascinated by a lot of different things and that's,
you take yourself and just like you're saying there,
the research is you'll immerse yourself into really knowing and finding
something out.
And uh,
you find a lot of different things.
Fascinating.
And one thing that's really cool when you're talking about the hunting and when
you were first,
when you first did a podcast with Rinella and then you kind of were educating
yourself along the way as you got into the hunting part of it,
it was almost like,
it's,
and I don't know if you've gone back and listened to of your old podcast
when you did those,
but it's like,
it was like a little kid,
you know,
just learning something new.
And I'm like,
that's pretty cool,
you know,
because here you have a,
a grown man asking questions that my 10 year old's asking me,
Daddy,
why are you doing this?
And this or that.
I'm like,
I dunno.
Ask Rogan.
I'm like that with you though.
Yeah.
Mark's like,
ah,
but it's uh,
you know,
it's,
it's cool to see,
and that's one of the questions that I had for you is it's like,
well,
what got you into hunting?
Why did you want to start hunting?
Well,
my wife would be best able to answer that because she's been mocking me for
watching Ted Nugent,
spirit of the wild for the past.
Like I mock you for watching til 11,
12 plus years.
I watch it for a lot of reasons.
One of it,
one of it is because it is fucking unbelievably hokey.
I mean,
he's just a hokey dude.
He's a crate.
He's a,
a master showman,
you know?
And if you've ever seen Ted Nugent play guitar,
ever seen his band,
he's a master showman and he uses a lot of that showmanship on his show.
And you know,
some of it is like really ridiculous.
You know,
some of it is like rare,
very repetitive and very over the top.
But I was fascinated by his promotion of this lifestyle,
this hunting lifestyle.
You know,
he has a,
at the time he didn't have the place in Texas.
He had his place in Michigan is a high fence operation and he would just kind to
go out into,
I don't know,
any hundreds of acres.
He has set up tree stands and wait for deer and shoot them.
And that's all the meat that he ate,
donated it to hunters for the homeless and hunters for the hungry or whatever it
is and you know,
and it really constantly promoted how healthy the lifestyle is,
how healthy the meat is and how this is like,
this is about sustainability.
This is about,
these animals are providing him with sustenance and in turn he is providing,
um,
he puts up food plots.
He's planting trees.
Like his whole thing is,
it's very balanced in a way that a lot of people who eat organic food that they
buy at whole foods and they think they're being all earthy life.
Mine too,
you're not,
you're not really balanced like Ted Nugent living in Michigan is more balanced
than you.
I know you don't think that,
but that's the reality.
The reality for a lot of people that go to the grocery store and pick up their
organic food is like,
man,
you don't know how many people were involved in the creating of that food.
What,
what,
what was putting in the soil?
It's organic.
There's no pesticides allegedly,
but it's organic because some inspectors stamped at the sand.
It is the organic.
Okay.
You don't use this pesticide which you used this chemical so,
but it's okay.
It's organic.
Yeah.
The word organic is a weird word to it's,
it's too open ended.
I just,
I don't market it.
Yeah.
I don't,
I don't know the exact definition of organic groceries are,
but there's a difference between groceries that you buy and groceries that you
grow and I grow a lot of vegetables now and um,
I've been doing that over the last say,
year and a half,
two years.
And again,
it's something super fucking satisfying about plucking it tomato slicing and
eating it in cooking.
You know,
putting in a salad tomato that you grow,
you put that seed in there,
you water it,
it grew,
you plucked it.
It's the whole cycle.
The whole cycle comes together.
So I started watching that show and I'm from then I just had got one of these
days I want to fucking go hunting.
And then I started watching Rinella show.
I was watching all kinds of hunting shows for like a decade before I ever went
hunting dog.
Gotcha.
Yeah.
People would come over my house and look at my DVR and we were like,
what the fuck is wrong with you?
Y'All morbid,
you get this weird twisted.
Yeah.
When animals attack kickboxing,
MMA hunting shows like what the fuck is wrong with you?
I don't know.
I don't know what's wrong with me,
but that's how I got into it.
So until I met Rinella,
I never actually went hunting.
Right.
The hunt you did with him?
Was it Alaska or something to carry first one?
No,
the first one was a mule deer in Montana.
Okay.
We went to,
um,
the,
uh,
the Missouri River.
We did a float trip.
It was really fun.
I remember seeing something on the sportsman channel was touting the crap out of
that.
They're like meat eater,
you know,
Joe Rogan goes on,
meteor does this.
And I'm like,
who's Joe Rogan?
I know me neither is,
but I didn't know who Joe Rogan was and I didn't know what the big deal about it
was.
And then I watched the episode,
I'm like,
I guys,
it seems pretty funny,
you know,
whatever.
And then it wasn't until like mark when,
I mean,
this wasn't very long ago.
I'll be,
I'll had been,
I haven't,
I haven't.
And I'm like,
I got to get to know more of this Joe Rogan cause he's getting into hunting,
you know,
he's doing stuff with Rinella now.
All the sudden shoot,
he's doing a podcast with cam and it's like,
okay,
I got to get to get to know this a little bit more.
And because I'll be honest,
I was like Brogan,
he could have been jungle or an acrobat as far as I had no idea.
No idea.
You're a totally immersed in the hunting world.
Well that's your worlds.
What's funny to you?
You asked me the last time I've watched a meat eater episode two years ago,
year and a half ago.
I don't know.
I just,
I've watched one episode of uncharted,
you know,
I just don't watch the shows anymore because I don't know.
I'm making them,
I guess help me still watching busy too.
Yeah.
It's not that I'm that busy.
I mean,
I definitely am busy,
but I have my home life too.
You know?
I spent a lot of time at home,
but I just don't spend it watching TV anymore.
I used to a lot.
I used to,
I mean when I first started producing television,
I would watch all the top rated shows.
I'm like,
oh,
I don't know what else is doing.
I want to know what Lee and Tiffany,
I want to know what all these people are doing and I'm going to do it because
it's successful.
It's a format.
And then I started solo and it was like all everything went out the window.
It's like,
you know what?
I'm going to do everything to these people don't do because I'm sick of seeing
the exact same thing every time.
And this conversation out of conversation with a big sponsor the other day
because they're wanting to produce a TV show and we had a big conference call
and everybody was talking about all the things they hate about television and
what things that they like about television.
And a lot of these different shows came up and then without a doubt they're all
like,
we hate out hokey.
It is.
We had how overproduced it is and this and that and that and,
but at the end of the day,
something's got to die,
you know,
and it's like
everything is the same.
The comments that you get from people as all the hunting shows the same,
you know?
And so to do something different is really hard.
Well there are a lot of them that are saying,
there's so many shows out there right now because of the networks that are,
that are available that there's a lot of shows that are different.
A lot of shows that,
that,
you know,
have their heartland bowhunter pretty different.
Yeah.
Are shows that have their own brand,
you know,
a lot of people emulate and try to copy what,
what heartland bow on her started and what they've done.
And so you're starting to see a lot of that imagery and that type of shooting
into different productions.
And I,
you know,
I,
I'll be admit,
I fall into a lot of that too,
where it's like,
man,
I want to do a shot that looks like that,
but I want to do it my way,
right.
For ours,
for Solo,
what,
what I think makes it unique is the fact that no matter how we film it,
it doesn't really matter because at the end of the day,
we're one man out there.
We're trying to kill an animal,
we're going to kill it,
we're going to bring it home,
you know,
and we're just trying to document that adventure.
I think by doing it by ourselves and having that relationship with the camera
where everything seems to be so close up and like,
it's like I'm talking to you,
you know,
you're,
you're watching,
I'm trying to talk to the viewer and communicate that.
And that's really hard to do because sometimes you want to just reenact and
restate what's happening or what's going on or what you're gonna do.
But what,
what mark and I are working on with,
with some of these other projects and what we're going to try to bring into solo
is more of that,
uh,
more of that.
What's going on up here.
You know,
what's going on in my head more so than what's going on with this.
You're seeing people want to know more what I'm thinking while I'm doing certain
things than actually what I'm doing,
I think.
And so that's an element from a,
as a producer to try to bring into it to where if people really knew what goes
on in my head while I'm up on the mountain,
I think they'd be shocked because it's not,
you know,
it's not all,
it's not all just complete focus on,
on hiking and hunting and killing,
you know,
there's a lot of different things that go on,
meaning that like you start thinking about your families,
start thinking about your life.
Well,
that kind of thing.
Yeah.
That,
and it's like,
you know,
I may,
I may be sitting there one time,
I may be thinking,
you know,
I'm going home,
I've been up here for four days.
I haven't seen a damn antler to Antler antlered animal for the last four days.
I'm going home.
But you have this,
you know,
this,
all this interaction that goes on in my head is like the guilt.
Okay,
if I go home,
I've just wasted four days that I've got here that I should have been here to
potentially get an episode,
you know,
or two potentially harvest an animal,
bring it home to eat it.
You know,
I'm,
I'm wasting that.
If I go home now I'm a quitter.
If I stay at,
stick it out.
I'm stupid because I'm not gonna find any animals or whatever.
So there's this constant,
because when you're by yourself,
there's nobody to talk you into things and there's nobody to talk to you out of
things.
So when you make a decision,
it's yours and you got to live with it.
You got to do it,
you know?
So if I'm hiking up a mountain and a deer is bedded somewhere and I know that if
I hike around this way two miles,
I can get to him without him winning me.
Or like I did on the last day of my hunt,
I took it.
I said,
yeah,
it's a gamble.
The wind's blown here.
If I go here,
it's,
it's iffy.
But if I go here,
I can,
it's,
I can cut off two miles of distance,
but I might have a chance to get on him.
But if I go this way,
it's two miles.
But it's a guarantee I could get it on him without the wind.
Well,
the last day I chose the shortcut and what did I do?
I blew the deer out.
You know,
the deer,
the deer caught my scent and it was gone.
You know,
one thing that works for covering sent,
cause you were using some stuff on the episode that I saw last week where you
were,
that knows blocker.
I tried that nose jammer stuff.
That stuff's different.
I guess.
I'm not as,
I'm not a cent guy.
I'm not a cover Sant guy.
I'm not a,
you don't believe in it.
I don't think they're trying to convince me this that works and it may work.
But there was an instance on that episode because I don't want to down talk nose
jammer,
you know,
because they're,
they're,
they're advertising on the show but it's not,
it's a product that I taught.
I committed to him when I met the owner,
I met John Redmond at a trade show and in Reno and he was so stinking passionate
about it and I told him to his face,
I'm like,
John,
I don't believe in that stuff,
man.
It's all hokey.
It's smells,
smells funny.
I don't want anything to smell.
And he's like,
no,
try it,
blah blah,
blah,
blah.
So it turns out I,
he gives me a candidate stuff and I try it there in Oklahoma.
That's the first time I'd ever tried it.
And there was a buck that came down wind and he obviously smelled something.
Yeah,
you could tell.
He was like,
yeah,
he's like,
that was awesome because I was like,
cause he smelling.
But you know what?
The deer could have done that by smelling me or he was smelling the vanilla that
I just rubbed it all over the tree or whatever that was,
whatever's in the nose jammer.
But something confused his sensory glance.
And that's the point behind nose jammer I guess as the tenant Kinda confused
their sensory glands.
So it just pauses them just for that one minute.
So hopefully you can get a shot at him.
But it did it,
it held that deer up and then he,
then he moved on.
So there was,
there's some validity to that to that I guess.
But would that deer have done the same thing if I rubbed coconut oil on,
on my pants,
you know,
who knows?
I don't know.
Right.
How could you tell?
You'd have to have the exact same scenario with the exact same animal and a
bunch of different options.
And that's why for me personally,
I've had so much experience in the field and then I've had so many times when
I've tried different things and times when I've just gone natural,
you know,
where it's just me and my body odor or that's it.
And ultimately at the end of the day,
my conclusion has been in it and it is to today to,
and that's not to say that it's can't change over time.
And as I,
as I have more hunting experiences,
but right now I don't want to interject any foreigns scent into the air.
You know,
I want,
I'm going to have a smell to me.
No matter what I do,
no matter what I shower in,
no matter what I spray my clothes down with,
doesn't matter.
I'm going to smell a certain way that is not natural to that environment.
So when that deer walks into his bedroom,
because a deer,
a deer is never anywhere by chance.
He's never anywhere randomly.
He's,
he's walking where he's walking for a reason,
you know,
he knows that that's a safety corridor where he can transfer,
where he can move himself from food to bed or whatever safely.
And so he's there for a reason.
So if he smells anything out of the ordinary or sees anything out of the
ordinary,
he's automatically going to be on alert.
And you know that there's variations to everything because crop land and where
you hunt some of these white tails,
it's farm land where I hunt there in Oklahoma,
it's an operating cattle ranch.
So the deer could have smelled people before had to have,
because there's oil rigs in there where there's people in and out.
So they know what people smell like.
So to me,
I use that into my,
into my little thinking is that if they know what human smell,
like they want to avoid it.
So they're traveling these corridors because they know they can avoid humans.
So they're just traveling where he's traveling because he knows he's not going
to have any interaction with,
with anything but a deer.
Right.
So to me,
I use that as well.
That's the point where I want to be and I want to get to so I can kill him,
you know?
So if he smells anything,
guys,
getting back to the same thing,
if he smells anything out of the ordinary,
it's,
you're the gigs up anyway.
So in deer having insane capability,
oh yeah.
For Smell,
right?
Yeah.
I mean,
you're,
they say,
I don't know the exact numbers.
I mean,
I'm not a technical guy.
I'm more of a live in the now,
you know,
feel how I feel kind of kind of person.
So,
you know,
I've had experiences where a deer has been thousand 1500 yards down wind and he
smells me.
It blows me away.
It's like that theory is 1500 yards away from me and he smells me and he takes
out because in the West you can see that,
you can see what goes on.
So when you're sneaking around and you see that deer poke his head up and you
know,
you,
you know,
when they're smelling and they're gone,
if they smell you,
they're out of there.
But you know,
when I was hunting this year,
there's several times where I bumped these two big bucks.
I bumped him three different times.
The first two times they just saw me and they didn't smell me and they just kind
of moseyed off.
They were like,
something's,
something's weird over there.
You know,
it's that Bush isn't supposed to be moving like that.
But then the one time that they smelled me,
they didn't see me.
They just smelled me and they were gone.
I mean,
they booked it.
They,
they smell your breath.
Like what are they smelling?
Yeah,
I'd do everything for it in the woods,
don't you?
I mean,
well there's,
there's,
it depends,
it's breath,
but,
but it's,
it's,
we have a sense,
you know,
I just smell myself right now sitting here,
but it's like we have it,
we have an aroma about us just like they have an aroma about them,
you know,
so you could wash your clothes in the San free stuff,
you spray,
whatever.
But you know,
30 minutes into a hike,
I'm,
I'm sweating and smelling like you swells.
You know,
you could maybe eliminate the very outskirts of their ability where they even
tried.
Just play the wind.
Well,
I mean,
and that's hard too because it's like,
you know,
there's millions of dollars advertising dollars spent in promoting,
sent elimination products and a lot of,
some of my sponsors promotes sent elimination clothing or whatever.
And at the end of the day,
all that stuff can help.
It can eliminate,
like you're saying,
it can take your,
your scent Roma from here to here,
which is good.
That's your advantage.
But what about those things,
those ozone things that people picking on me for that I don't know was zonnic I
dealt with those on with water but I dunno.
I Dunno.
It was at the giant box sits above your crease Stan.
Does it play music cause it like to need like yeah.
Muzak somethings like elevator music to calm them down and put some
air cleaner thing.
It's the ozone and it puts out,
which I'm experienced with ozone with water when I worked with her for a water
company is the ozone is a,
it's a form of sanitize,
sanitize.
It keeps,
it keeps the lines clean and it keeps,
it keeps everything clean.
So I guess if you inject that into the air and you can smell ozone like after a
good heavy rainstorm or something,
you can smell the ozone in the air.
You can smell this,
smell it.
The ozone from the ozone layer.
From the,
yeah,
from just from the environment.
Your hands.
Yeah,
it disables the ions.
And does something.
Yeah.
Um,
you can get them for your house.
I know people that have gotten in their house and it lowers the dust levels.
Allergens really paralyzes it.
Brings it right to,
yeah,
but isn't ozone toxic in hive?
Yeah.
You can get yourself pretty sick from it if you,
so if you're just sitting in a tree stand blowing ozone on your face.
I can't speak to it.
To me.
I Dunno man.
That's one more thing that I got off the tree.
I don't,
I'm never going to use one.
I mean,
they could come to me and say,
Hey,
we'll give you 50 grand to use this thing.
I'll be like,
I'll take your 50 grand,
but I can't use it.
Wow.
How rude saying this,
our podcasts,
ladies and gentlemen,
you know.
Well good for y'all.
Straight,
honest.
No.
I've turned down,
I had a sponsorship at one time with a scent elimination company and they wanted
to grow that sponsorship.
They,
of course there was other pretends to a to move to another network and different
things.
And I ended up turning that down because it's,
it's f and I told him exactly,
I'm like,
this is not a product that I can get behind 100% and if I can't,
if I can't believe in what it is that people are gonna see right through that.
So for me it's like that money that you're going to give me,
it does.
Does,
does this both no good.
So I discontinued that relationship with that sponsor.
Yeah.
I feel the same way about sponsors for the podcast.
I,
I've turned down a bunch.
I've turned down one recently.
It was pretty lucrative,
but I be like,
I don't like it.
I don't like what they're selling.
I don't like the idea not doing it.
And I'm with the TV show,
some of it,
you know,
you see some of the ads or the,
the billboards that are running in the show and everything.
What a person's got to realize too from a production standpoint is is we have
sponsors,
you know,
quote unquote sponsors that we are backing under armor,
prime g five all these that that our backers and investors,
yeah,
they're pretty much investors in the,
in you and in your business and your brand,
and then there's ads that you sell,
you know,
32nd commercial spots,
those types of things.
That's ad placement that either the network's going to put in there or I'm going
to sell it to somebody to put it in there.
Yeah,
that's a,
maybe you be understand how outdoor show your work.
The outdoor shows work a little bit different than a lot of their shows.
A lot of times they get like say if a guy puts on a show like solo hunter,
you have a certain amount of advertising space that's for you,
for your program,
but then the network has a certain amount of advertising space of their own for
their things.
Like I got to tell Rinella about an advertiser that was competing with one of
his friend's companies that was on the same Chicago.
Do you know that you guys are selling this on your show you those what we're
selling that I go,
yeah,
your show had an ad for this,
which is a rip off because they didn't protect the category.
Yeah,
exactly.
For like under Armour and some of these other,
these the major sponsors,
you protect categories.
So when somebody buys a commercial spot on the show for say that's protected,
I'm not going to go out and find another clothing guy,
can't sponsor any of that.
I'm,
I'm exclusive for these guys.
And so yeah,
that makes sense.
So it's for folks who don't know what you're exactly how you're saying it's,
it's a kind of a unique thing.
You kind of buying time on a,
on a,
on the network.
That's one thing I tell people you know,
is,
is there's no rule book,
but there's no playbook either.
So the networks,
there's a lot of variations.
You know,
the majority of hunting shows out there,
they're called time bias,
where we,
by the time we buy that 30 minute block on the network and then we,
we buy a certain amount of advertising and we sell that advertising.
And then whatever advertising we don't buy from the network because it within a
30 minute or 30 minute block,
you have six minutes of commercial time.
So it's,
it's three,
two minute commercial breaks.
So whether I buy any of those commercial times are not outdoor channels going to
put in three,
two minute breaks into that,
that programming.
So my 30 minutes turns into 22 minutes,
you know.
So what I do is I buy however many 32nd commercial spots I can sell.
I buy that from the network,
I turn around and sell that a margin.
Then within the show content,
there's,
you know,
I get paid to where somebody is hat I get paid to where somebody's shirt.
You know,
if I use a product,
I get paid and there's different ad placements in there and so it becomes more
of,
people think that it's all about hunting.
Hunting's the fun part,
you know?
But for me,
the business is the fun part too.
So you're,
you're trying to calculate in that 30 minutes,
how can I maximize,
maximize my revenue,
you know,
because you can only have,
you have a limited number of,
of advertising spots that you can put in there.
So it's who can I,
who can I contract and who's who,
who can we fit in certain places?
It's a very interesting way to produce television.
A lot of folks aren't aware of.
It's cool in a way because there are shows on the hunting television that are
more like discovery channel where the network pays for them to be produced and
they actually own the content.
They're called outdoor channel.
Originals were on sportsman channel,
I don't know what they're called,
whatever more the network is invested into these shows or they'd give them the,
our time for certain.
There's,
there's,
there's a myriad of ways things can be done,
but I want to own at the end of the day,
I want to own solo hunter and I want to own timber net.
I want all my brand,
you know,
I don't want,
just because they're buying the show off me,
I don't want to have them have any control over me or what I do or what I say or
what advertisers I can bring in.
So at the end of the day,
yeah,
I'm,
I'm having to front some money and run it as a business rather than somebody's
paying me to produce a show.
But at the end of the day,
there's no limit to what I can make.
You know,
there's no limit to the advertising that I can sell and I own myself.
I own the shell on the brand.
Are you aware of this whole sort of movement that's going on right now on
television,
on regular television,
like the history channel and a lot of these other channels where they're really
concentrating on people that are trying to live sustainable lives?
Yeah,
like the Alaska shows like Alaska last frontier or,
um,
there's that other show life below zero.
You ever seen that show?
It's a good show.
It's a lot of,
a lot of it is hunting and uh,
I follow that stuff probably more than I do in the hunting industry because to
me that's,
it's obviously mainstream,
but it's more fascinating because you don't have
individual little guys like me conceptualizing and coming up with the content.
You have big boys in big rooms making big decisions with big,
big checks,
doing big analysis on viewership and on what people are looking for and all
that.
You have them creating the concepts and the ideas.
So to me it's like those are the people I want wanna I want to watch because
those are the people with the brains and the backing behind them knowing with
the,
with their hand on the pulse of what society is looking for.
So I follow the allegedly allegedly,
which,
you know,
yeah,
I mean most of the time they just TV fuckheads the hard thing with that is,
is like,
you know,
there's a larger part of society that are non hunters,
non outdoors when there are that are,
you know,
outdoorsman puts,
you're starting to see a lot of content,
you know,
people trying to portray that lifestyle.
Yeah.
That's why I asked you because I think it's,
uh,
there's,
there's this movement right now,
uh,
and you see it in like weird ways.
Like you see it like preppers.
I'm like,
Oh,
I have these weird people that are like canning foods and digging holes in their
backyard and burned water bottles.
They can dumps in coffee cans,
whatever.
Well,
preppers,
it's weird,
you know,
because some of them were like living in cities and they're putting all this
stuff together and you know,
I kinda got news for you.
If you're living in a city and the shit hits the fan,
you better get the fuck out of that city.
That's what I told my wife.
I'm like,
you know,
a lot.
I'm flying through Vegas into La on nine 11 it's like,
ah,
there's nowhere to go.
Like I don't know how you guys do it down here.
There's nowhere to escape.
You don't know where I'm at.
I'm like,
okay,
I have the back door gone.
Middle of the Nevada desert,
you'll have,
you'll never find me.
But here it's like,
man,
you can't.
Well,
it's going to be also,
you're going to be surrounded by a bunch of people who don't have any food,
who don't have any water here and they're going to find out that you have food
and water.
You better have a lot of bullets and fucking Adderall to stay away.
Don't let people know you've got a year supply of food.
Yeah,
don't get on a prepper show,
but it shows the fuck in front of your house and all your neighbors know where
your stored food is.
Crap hits the fan.
There's a lot of us that are in trouble.
Ultimately society is going to have to bond together.
And those though,
that's where,
that's where religion,
a lot of these groups will come together and that's where it will become
valuable.
And you know,
for,
for people that don't see it as like,
that's where little groups,
communities,
you know,
it's where if you don't know your neighbor man,
you should go your stinking neighbor because the guy might be in,
my guy might be covering your back one night,
you know,
maybe.
So you need to know your area and you know,
yeah,
it's the fan.
We're all screwed anyways.
Yeah.
You're almost like,
I was listened to this other show that I've listened to all the time called
radio lab,
uh,
is a podcast and they were talking about,
the,
the impact that killed the dinosaurs.
And uh,
when they were talking about it,
it was like,
dude,
you're just going over like what the original human was like this thing that
allegedly came out of that impact,
like what animals,
what fossils they know of.
And it's almost like you rather get hit in the head by the,
I then go through all that shit.
I know,
you know,
you don't want to be the people that have babies in,
in a pop apocalyptic environment and then those babies grow onto it.
Like fuck man,
be glad you live in an era where they could make cotton really,
really soft us.
You know,
he got soft blankets and warm heat and you don't have to deal with,
I'm a big fan of civilization but I am a big fan of this.
Well we were talking about the prepper thing because I think there's this,
people are sort of realizing as people pay more attention to a lot of the issues
that society has,
whether it's a environmental issues like um,
whether it's pollution or garbage is being dumped into the ocean or the amount
of a fish that's getting pulled out of the ocean sustainability.
And they start looking at the ideas of like where their food comes from.
Like people are really into grass fed beef now.
Grass Fed beef is a big thing.
It was fucking nonexistent 10 years ago.
You never saw grass fed beef anywhere.
Almost every supermarket I go to now it has like a little section grass fed
meat,
you know,
and people were concerned about animals that are eating what they're supposed to
be eating instead of some weird fucking great news for people is beef.
You know,
being here in the West,
you know,
we see a lot of that and uh,
the majority of its life is grass fed.
They turn them out on the range they pay,
they pay fees for the Blm or wherever is there.
Grass fed up until about three months at the end of their life where they're put
onto a feed lot,
fed a bunch of fat foods fattened up.
So they taste good when I put them on the grill,
you know what I mean?
That's,
there's a reason why,
in my opinion,
why food's been engineered and,
and changed is because it makes them,
we've got a lot of pop,
a lot of people to feed for one,
but so in a way that's good,
but as long as I can go out and distill,
obtain a deer tag or an elk tag and go out and get my own meat for myself,
I'm going to continue to do that.
You know,
it's just,
it's a totally different kind of meat.
That was the,
the point is that the,
when you eat a steak from an elk or a deer and then you eat a steak from a cow,
like one of them is a fat,
Lazy Fuck.
That's like,
like marbling.
Like that Shit's not supposed to be their taste.
So good.
Well,
I had a rib eye last night.
A bone in Ribeye.
Oh,
it's delicious.
I'm sure it was not fucking grass fed whatsoever.
Partner and saw grass probably never feared for his life either.
Oh,
probably not to the end.
It didn't even know the end.
You know,
the axe fell and I don't think it's an ax.
I don't know what it is.
A Piston Histon what it is that thing like uh,
no country for old men,
that thing he uses that just take a ride foreheads then they take a ride and go.
I remember in high school I watched a video on uh,
on the butchering process,
you know,
and uh,
that made me sick when,
when they,
when they killed the cow made me,
made me sick after that,
it wasn't that big of a deal,
you know,
cause I've dealt with that before.
But what's weird is when they do it kosher style like kosher,
you have to cut its throat and it suffers way more.
It's very strange.
Like they
have rules and a lot of the rules are,
we're like old school religious rules.
Like the reason why you're not supposed to eat pigs once because a lot of pigs
carry trick analysis.
That's what they did back in the day at least.
And so they were telling people don't eat pigs.
Why?
Because people eat pigs.
They got really fucking sick.
So they wrote it down.
Don't eat pigs against the religion.
I grew up,
you know what I mean?
You talk about organic.
Can you talk about raw,
I mean,
the way I grew up is probably about as organic and raw as you can get.
I mean whole milk straight from the cow.
You milk the cow.
I'd take it in,
strain it through a cloth,
you know,
a cloth,
chill it,
skim the cream off or shake it in and you drink it,
you know,
no pasteurization,
nothing.
That's how,
that's how I grew up.
There was a time there when when my dad was a farmer and he lost the farm so he
had to go back to college.
Well there was a big time stretch in there where we had to sustain off the land.
You know her off of the farm.
We had animals to eat and you know,
the farmers would come and drop off a sack of potatoes because they knew that,
you know,
these,
those little raggedy kids,
you know,
all their dad's off go on to college and mom was trying to take care of them
and,
and so we literally lived off the land.
So your dad was somewhere else.
And you were on the phone.
I went to college in Provo,
Utah while we lived in central Idaho.
You know,
cause he was,
went back to school to get his teaching degree because we lost the farm now,
um,
me,
he was a potato farmer for a long time.
So we're living on the farm and it wasn't,
it wasn't unusual for mom to go out grab one of the rabbits that we're raising
and I'll never forget the first rabbit,
you know,
that I've washed,
washed her kill,
hung it up,
smacked it on the head.
And you know,
we,
we had rabbit for dinner and it was,
there was a lot of times where it's like,
Timothy,
can you go grab a chicken?
You know,
we need,
we need some,
we need dinner or whatever.
And you'd go out and you'd get a chicken and you,
you take care of it and bring it in.
You know,
there,
it's just part of the lifestyle that I grew up that you didn't go to the grocery
store and get things.
You went out to the garden and you pulled off a Zucchini,
you know,
you went and pulled some tomatoes.
You what was really cool as the irrigation system that was there,
the little ditches,
I mean asparagus everywhere,
wild rhubarb.
I mean there's all these different kinds of things that we probably did out of
necessity during that time span.
More so than out of,
yeah,
we're going to live off of our farm and live off of what we create.
But I think that timespan taught me a lot about the reality of life and death.
The reality of hey,
you can create and be so completely self sustained,
you know,
you can be create your own food,
everything right here just on one tiny little farm.
And then also,
you know,
that's,
that's what kind of gave me a love and a passion with animals because you're
raising,
you know,
a calf from the time it's born,
you're bottle feeding it,
you're feeding it all through,
through the wintertime,
you know,
breaking the ice off the water trough and everything else.
The next spring you're killing it and then you're going to eat it.
You know?
So there's that,
that whole span where you go from life to death in a five,
six,
eight month period of,
and
as a young kid that could be either traumatic or that can be a major life
learning experience.
You know?
And I took that as this is the way life is.
That's the way,
that's the way things happen.
So when I grew up,
when you get older and you get to college and people start throwing the Ah,
you,
you know,
you eat animals or this and that and,
and the vegetarian stuff and you start learning the things of the world.
That's where it's like,
man,
you people are the ones that are crazy,
not me.
You know?
Yeah.
There's just so much ignorance involved in people that live in cities and you
know,
claim that there's something wrong with people that eat animals.
It's the,
the,
what's wrong is factory farming there.
There's something wrong about factory farms.
There's something wrong about jamming a bunch of chickens into a box.
It's so small they can't move and they cut their beaks off so they don't peck
each other.
Do they have?
That's the thing is do they have to do that in order to provide enough food for
people?
That's,
that's right.
I don't know.
That's where I'm ignorant on the subject because it's like,
man,
part of it is like,
well,
we got to produce food.
We've got to have GMOs,
we got to have grain grow faster.
We got to have these different things just to provide food for people.
There's so many,
because we're providing food for people all over the world,
so it's like,
Dang,
where's the fine line there?
You know,
where's,
where's the good point?
I just think that the ethics involved in,
in raising animals,
I think it is important.
It is,
and it's important that these animals don't suffer needlessly,
but the idea that eating them is wrong.
It's like,
boy,
there's some weird,
it's,
it's a very shallow minded argument in my opinion,
or the,
not shallow minded,
but the,
the,
the exploration of that idea,
the exploration of that idea is,
it's kind of simplistic because if you just let the animals free,
okay.
No more,
no more livestock,
no more of this.
Well,
what are you gonna do with all those animals?
You can just let them roam free and if you let them roam free,
how are you planning on driving anywhere?
Because if you're planning on going play,
if you want to keep them penned up and you want to keep feeding them and they
just not eat them,
okay,
well what are you going to do when there's too many of them?
Well,
there shouldn't have been that many to begin with,
you know?
Or it's because of the factory farming that there are that many pigs are that
many turkeys or whatever.
But do you know what they're doing in the Hamptons,
the Hamptons,
like a really rich area or on your,
your podcast.
That's the first time I heard about that.
They're trying to give them birth control to try and give dear birth control.
I mean hundreds of hours they doing it.
Are they doing it right now?
Shut the fuck is wrong with these babies.
There's control in certain cities.
I think birth control,
it's like,
you know,
it's a 22 cent three away out of that.
I mean that's birth control,
right,
or arrows.
I mean,
and one of the shows,
uh,
Waddell and um,
that dude never own,
never heard of it.
He knows guys,
never heard of them.
They uh,
went to uh,
New Jersey and they were in like this residential neighborhood in New Jersey
that has a deer problem.
So they were like posted up on these tree stands and these people's backyards
just fucking deer everywhere.
These guys,
he'd mark here grew up in New York?
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
So that places mobbed Mario dear.
Yeah.
You can't even drive at night.
So then what they do is they shut down the parks and they allow you to go and
after all the gear season's done and you're allowed to take up to five dear.
Wow.
It's so controlled that they want to know at the end of every day you have to
log on a piece of paper,
part of your license,
what you've seen and how many,
what are they were the guys in Boston,
like Mitch and Tim were,
they were showing me where they were hunting.
Right.
I went to visit my,
it was like five minutes away from New Plymouth Rock.
You know what?
All the hunting right there on the ocean and everything.
I was just like,
man,
that's crazy.
Just overwhelmed with like urban dear or suburban suburban dear.
Yeah.
That's a big issue also with ticks because those deer,
the ones that are carrying those deer ticks and those are the ones that are
carrying that Lyme disease.
And my room substeps obsessed with ticks every,
every time she talks to me on the phone.
Did you check yourself for ticks?
Nah,
babe,
I can't see that for yourself or take Rinella.
And His kid both got Lyme disease and every one of his producers never heard of
him.
He got uh,
he got it really bad though.
He had bell's Palsy.
I don't know if all of us said,
yeah,
that's crazy.
It was ugly.
But he was saying on the last podcast I did with them,
but they,
they did some study of ticks in the Hudson Valley and Valley county or
something.
Like 70 to 80% of them have Lyme disease.
It's a fucking epidemic.
That's crazy.
Well,
they had a stink in what's from a call it a burning man in Nevada out there.
I guess a bunch of people got not West Nile from the all the mosquito,
six gas,
16 to 23,000 people.
What came down with Wes?
Not yet.
All the more reason I got to go to burning man,
there's no need for any more reasons to not go to Berlin.
But if you did need one,
that's it.
If I go to burning man,
it's the handout soap.
I do find myself up on the mountain though sometimes.
You're like,
oh,
what if I got any ticks?
But you know,
I've never,
I mean there's,
when I,
that deer I shot last week,
holy cow.
Did you see the Cape?
There's ticks everywhere.
Just covered literally.
Just,
and what's crazy is when,
uh,
after the animal dies and you're,
you're,
you,
I brought it back and I kept it out and everything,
which is,
if you don't know what caping is,
is,
is when you take the hide for mounting,
you know,
so you take it off the head and neck and you bring it back Utan it.
And you have a mountain so you can preserve your,
whether it's a trophy or you can preserve your memories or whatever it is.
But once it dies and it goes through the cooling process,
the ticks note don't have anywhere warm to stay at anymore and there's no blood
and there's nothing.
So they just start coming out like crazy.
And uh,
I mean there was just this pile of ticks.
I was like,
man,
that's,
you kill him.
What do he do?
I just let them down.
You can't kill a tick.
I mean we used to on one,
we'd have sheep and stuff when we'd be on the farm.
You'd kind of roll your fingernail over and crush them and try to kill them.
But they're tough.
They're like a fleet.
Just don't get them on.
Yeah.
They're,
they're bad.
They're Yucky.
I couldn't have Lyme disease.
I would never know.
I think you just start feeling like shit.
Some days you feel bad,
some days you could,
well,
they say that.
Do you remember were like in the eighties or nineties a
lot of people were coming down with chronic fatigue syndrome.
They linked it to Lyme disease?
Is that what you're,
yeah,
people were saying,
well there was,
it was a real issue like people saying,
oh you know,
my friend has chronic fatigue syndrome.
Like what does,
what does that mean?
Well sometimes people just get,
for whatever reason,
they're just tired all the time.
Their body aches or why they don't know.
Well now they believe that a lot of those people have Lyme disease because
apparently there's a lot of doctors to this day that are reluctant to diagnose
someone with Lyme disease.
And that's what Rinell ran into with his kid.
He was like,
I think my kids got Lyme disease.
And then doctors like,
ah,
don't worry about it.
It's nothing.
And then it turns out at he did and you know,
he was really fucking pissed off cause he brought his kid in there three times,
but they'll sure slap them on Ritalin in a hurry.
Oh Yeah,
put your kid on Prozac and it'll help us.
Like if I took my kid and they'd be like,
ah,
he's add you gotta you gotta calm that kid down.
I'm like,
Nah,
man,
he's a boy.
He's no burning man.
Was Not infected with West Nile virus.
What,
what happened?
That's the,
that's the Huffington Post.
I want to believe that in that area.
Yeah.
And some traps,
but it wasn't on any people or only one case in that county.
So that whole last five minutes of that segment,
there was so many people out there screaming,
you guys are wrong.
You're so full of crap.
Every podcast I've ever done ever.
I got news every,
yeah.
It was no way around that.
It doesn't matter.
You just gotta do your thing.
I guess it's not 16,000.
It's zero,
close,
close mark.
But when you think about,
you know,
with 7 billion people on the planet,
you weren't
close enough.
Um,
so back to,
uh,
this,
this movement,
this trend that people are having to sort of,
I think a lot of it comes with people that are kind of trying to shy away from
Gmo foods and these people that are trying to move towards sustainability.
And I think that's what's being reflected in a lot of these shows.
Um,
but I find it fascinating that people are really into these shows that have
never had any desire to hunt.
And they accept it.
Like,
especially like life below zero is a really good one.
And they accept how these people live because well,
hey,
those people live out in the bush,
they have no choice.
And it's a unique lifestyle choice instead of,
you know,
hey Tim Barnett likes to go out and shoot things and hunt them and film it.
But I feel like it's the same thing.
I really do.
I feel like it's exactly the same thing.
It's just they've stylistically labeled it in a different way and it became,
you know,
a reality show about unique people.
Does that mean I have to accept the Hippie,
you know,
that's out there humping like minks all over and you know,
transmitting diseases everywhere because that's the lifestyle that they chose.
You know,
so it's like the hump weeks humping like names,
I don't know,
whatever.
I'm just like the animal,
then you're ruining my example.
The sand,
just because they're saying that it's acceptable because those people
interjected there themselves into that lifestyle.
So it's like,
okay,
so the people that are living of,
you know,
whatever lifestyle,
should I accept that?
Just because they're,
they're putting themselves into that lifestyle.
It's like,
I dunno.
Well,
I have no problem accepting any lifestyle.
It doesn't intrude on mine.
But when I see these,
um,
these reality shows,
whatever you want to call them,
where these people are living a sustainable life,
I just,
I find it super intriguing,
like almost like in a primal way.
Like I love watching those shows.
I think it's,
there's,
um,
life below zero.
There's one guy,
I think his name is Glenn,
and uh,
he lives deep in the woods.
Okay.
He lives right next to this lake and uh,
he doesn't have any power is no,
he doesn't have a fucking snowmobile.
Like there's levels that these guys do it.
Some guys have snow.
Will is one guy,
Eric,
he has a snowmobile and he traps and hunts and he sells the,
you know,
the first and things along those lines.
And so he gets some money for that,
for supply.
And then he also guides,
he's a hunting gun.
But this other guy,
Glen,
he's not none of that.
I mean all he has some furs that he sells and with that the money,
he gets bullets and that's basically what he has 10 camp,
you know,
pots and pans and things along those lines for cooking.
But everything he does,
he's,
he's chopping his own wood.
He makes his own fire with like one of those things.
He puts like the piece in its mouth with the stick so he can hold it in place
and does the whole thing with the fucking,
with the,
it looks like one of those things you play the violin with,
you know,
like a fire go.
Yeah,
a fire fireball.
But he,
it's an old school one where he holds a piece in his mouth that it keeps a stick
in place so he could like,
he like got a boy both hands for them.
Exactly.
Said it really gets pushed down with one arm.
So he bites down on it with his teeth,
holds the stick in place and he can make a fire pretty quickly like that.
It was pretty interesting to watch,
but he said,
hey,
you know,
you could lose matches,
matches,
get wet this side,
I'll never lose.
So he's gone.
So old school,
like come as as old school as old school gets and it's amazing.
It's fascinating.
But for this guide,
when he talks about it,
he talks about how exciting and enriching every day is for him.
Every day has a purpose.
Every day is,
you know,
acquiring food,
living off the land,
figuring out a way to store that food.
He's got this,
I'm like this meat cooler room that he's built that's a like a sod house.
So he has all this sod over it,
you know,
to kind of keep it in essentially underground keeping cool.
And he has all his meat hanging in there.
It's just,
it's,
it's incredibly fascinating that people are like tuned into this stuff and
geared and a lot of my friends that have never had any desire to hunt
whatsoever,
watch these shows and sort of sparks that little fascination inside of them.
It's gotta be good.
I mean,
that's gotta be a good thing.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah.
I mean that's just like Alaska,
the last frontier.
That's the one that I really liked and I think that one's kind of two fold.
The reason I like it is one because the cast,
the characters,
you know they're pretty pretty interesting and I like,
I like that.
But two it's,
it's the subsistence.
Yeah.
Subsistence lifestyle.
Yeah,
that,
that's an interesting one too because there's different people that are in that
family that do it different ways.
Like the one guy auto is a cattle rancher and he's got his cattle and then
there's the son who just decides no cattle ranching,
just going to go off a hunting,
don't do the whole thing,
you know?
Good luck.
Yeah,
good luck.
Well you need it can be done,
but man,
it's not as easy as people would think it is.
It's a 24 hour proposition.
And then there was,
there was one just on discovery channel and all must have only ran for a few
weeks called the hunt or something where they were documenting or following in
10 weeks or something.
Yeah,
that's James Hetfield from Metallica was the,
the host is the guy and he got a lot of flack for,
for going on there or something.
But it's like,
it's like,
you know,
the mainstream networks and I guess that's kind of a frustration too.
It's like,
well why can't a hunting show go mainstream?
What can a typical hung,
she'll go mainstream.
Well I dunno if society would accept that or not at a mainstream level.
And yet the discovery child can come out with a series like that that is hunting
and it's,
it's bears,
you know,
they're hunting bears.
It's like how,
why,
why is that okay for discovery channel do that,
but for me to go out and,
you know,
fill a deer and elk,
I think it's changing.
That's why I brought that up.
I,
and I was going to bring up the hunt because I think it is changing.
They tried to get James Hatfield removed from the Glastonbury Music Festival
because he hosts the hunt and they used a photograph that they said with him
standing over a grizzly bear,
but it wasn't even him.
It's not him.
But pull that photo up,
you know,
that photo of that guy who was the actual hunter,
um,
he,
he's been sort of,
I'm going out publicly and promoting this like I don't know why these,
these anti hunters use this photo of a guy who Kinda sorta looks like James
Hatfield,
but it's not James Hatfield at all.
So it's complete bullshit.
It's not,
he's,
what he's doing is just narrating it.
They took into,
you know,
this,
this idea and they ran with it and there being a really,
um,
dishonest with it.
This is the guy sitting there promoting that as James Hatfield.
Just because he was the narrator behind the series.
Yeah.
And will he kind of looks like I'm a little bit,
but it's not,
it's not James Hatfield at all.
That's James Hatfield.
I mean James had field does hunt,
but that's not him standing over that grizzly bear.
So the entire premise of this thing that they were doing to try to get people
off of a,
or get metallic or removed from this music festival was just a bullshit
photograph.
Have you had anything against you for,
for you going hunting?
Is we where it's like,
oh yeah,
don't let Rogan,
you know,
don't let him do anything with UFC anymore.
No.
How could you do that?
Cage fight.
That's the thing about being a cage fighting commentary.
You're already doing something so fucked up.
You know,
you're involved in what some people think is human cockfighting.
They don't really care if you go out and shoot animals.
But yeah,
I've had people angry at me.
Definitely people call me a piece of shit.
Especially for the bear.
The bear was a bit,
there's a photo of me and cam standing over this bear a shot and I got more heat
for that than anything I ever did.
But it Kinda,
I think it's because people have this,
what they call anthropomorphication I think is the word,
where they connect animals to shoot with human characteristics like Yogi bear
and fucking all these ridiculous.
And when we grew up that way,
we exactly welding those animals and they have this idea of what wildlife is
that's completely alien from wildlife itself.
Those folks that I went bear hunting with a Cameron Hanes and the rivets,
uh,
Johnny and Jenny Rivet,
they run this,
I'm living the dream,
uh,
outfit or company up in Alberta,
the nicest fucking people you ever want to meet your life.
And they have,
they have animals,
they have dogs,
they love their dogs.
They have a puppy.
Like people don't understand hunting would never imagine that these people go
out,
shoot bears all day and come home,
pet their puppy.
You know,
it's like,
to them it seems like completely contradictory and alien.
Like how do you decide what animals you're shooting and what animals you're,
you're petting
and I can respect,
I mean,
you can see why.
my wife's the same way and she's like,
how can you love animals so much?
And uh,
you know,
when you see a deer hit on the side of the road,
you're like,
aw man,
that sucks.
It's real.
And then the next week you go out and kill on.
She's like,
I don't get that.
And I'm like,
well,
it's,
it's hunting.
It's not killing.
You know,
she meat,
she eats meat.
Yeah.
She,
uh,
she's funny.
She'll try to,
like,
I'll cook up some elk steak or something and I'll be like,
and I got to admit I'm not a Rinella.
I'm not,
you know,
Remy is a great cook,
but I'm like,
I'm one of those guys,
I want a slab of meat.
I'm going to put it on the grill.
It's going to hit 120 degrees,
whatever,
and I'm going to eat it.
You know?
I mean,
that's,
it was like,
I don't want to spend my time preparing food.
I just want to eat it.
And so some of this stuff I cook doesn't taste that great,
you know?
And that's where it's like,
but it's me,
you know,
and it's meat that I killed and meet that I brought home,
so I'm going to eat it.
But to her it's like,
oh,
that's a waste of time.
So,
you know,
if I spent more time preparing it in,
aging it and doing whatever needs to be done with it rather than just cooking a
need,
and yet she,
she might taste it,
but who knows?
So she doesn't eat your game meat?
No,
I cooked one time when I was like,
this is the best,
it was tenderloin from an elk,
you know,
and,
and granted I cooked it on the grill like I probably shouldn't have and it was
doused with barbecue sauce.
I man,
you couldn't tell.
I couldn't tell because I was like,
I want this to taste exactly like beef,
which it did.
And she chewed on a,
took one bite into it and spit it out,
blah blah,
blah.
And of course my boy sees this so he's like,
I don't ever want to eat here ever again,
dad.
You know,
cause mom's spit it out and it's like,
no,
no.
Mom just doesn't like it.
But that's,
I don't know what it is.
I interesting hammer on it all the time.
Like,
man,
I just try it.
But she's like,
you can't even cook that in the house.
You know,
don't even cook it in the house.
She won't let you cook it in the house.
She will.
I mean,
she will.
It's not,
I mean,
I wear the pants around their,
damn it.
He's going to try to reclaim power.
He's letting me be the man.
No,
but yeah,
she's like,
if you're going to cook that go outside.
So it's like that's fine.
Put It on the grill and I'll chew the crap out of it.
Then I'll,
I'll eat it.
I,
I enjoy it.
Well,
my,
my wife grew up in a hunting family,
so she's used to eating like wild game.
She likes it and our kids have been eating it since,
uh,
I started hunting two years ago.
So when,
um,
my,
my youngest daughter was too,
there was like the first time she had deer.
So she's been eating deer since then.
Like they,
they'll eat anything.
Oh,
my kids,
my kids have been raised on,
I mean,
they've eaten more wild game than a lot of kids.
I'm sure they just don't know.
You know,
it's,
it's the same.
It's meat,
meat.
When we cook meat,
it's meat,
whether it's a deer and elk,
raw chicken,
whatever.
My,
my two year old,
she's,
everything's chicken,
chicken,
you know.
And it could be,
it could be a buffalo for all of it.
It doesn't matter.
Everything's Chechen.
Yeah,
it's,
it's a weird thing where people have this,
uh,
like this connection with some animals are like your friends and some animals.
Like you shouldn't,
you should never hunt this.
Like,
I have an agent,
she's a very nice person.
She loves animals,
but she told me,
Oh,
I don't mind if you kill pigs.
Wild pigs are discussing.
They're so ugly,
they're ugly.
You can kill them because they're ugly.
I'm like,
is it their fault that they're ugly?
That's the thing that kind of,
I'm going to,
it ticks me off because like,
the network promotes a support ellipse crap.
Oh yeah.
Here's the thing and a little background story to this.
I grew up on a,
on a farm,
obviously at one time we had a hog operation.
We had hundreds of pigs,
you know,
whatever.
But like,
I have a love for pigs.
I love the,
I love animals.
They got a personalities.
They're really cool,
you know,
I mean they're,
they're cool.
And so when I see somebody who will rename nameless on a TV show thing,
Ma'am shoot one arrow through two pigs and that's okay.
But yet,
if I shoot one arrow through to deer,
you know,
even if it's legal or to whatever,
it's not okay.
And then the very next minute shoot,
you know,
a weanling 10 pound pig in the head with a pellet rifle and watch it sit there
and flail on the ground.
That's bull crap.
You know?
Well,
it,
cause I had a relationship with that hot,
what?
That little pit.
It's like,
don't show me that.
Do it.
You can do it.
I don't care.
Don't show me that,
you know,
don't show public that because to me,
I think that the worst enemies for hunters and hunting television are hunters
and hunting television.
We're,
we're our worst,
worst advocate.
And I say we,
I lump us all on broad,
broad,
broad stroke is,
but it's,
it's like there's so many out there doing things that,
yeah,
it's the reality of it,
but it's not,
it's not what needs to be seen.
I know what you're saying.
And I'm gonna explain it to people who don't know what you're saying.
Um,
there,
there are certain shows and there's one show called pig man.
And I wasn't going to say I said it.
I said it.
Sorry,
Matt.
Um,
anyway,
uh,
pig man,
he,
the,
what they're doing a lot is population control rather than hunting.
And they are shooting animals,
but they're shooting animals that have overrun these farms.
So some of them,
when you were saying a porker lips,
what they're doing is they're getting these helicopters we've played video of,
it's the craziest shit ever have him and Nugent up in helicopters with fucking
automatic rifles
taken out pigs.
Like in mass,
they shot 450 of them or something in a day.
Once.
It's the craziest thing you've ever seen.
These pigs are running and they're boom headshot as they're running their
tumbling.
And it's not about like we're going to go out and shoot an animal,
harvest it,
and then use it and eat it and you know,
and show the hunting lifestyle.
No,
it's,
it's like it's a murder fest.
It's like pigs have a pass because of what they are.
You know what,
what they're doing.
I,
because they are causing billion,
probably billions of dollars in damage to the crop crops in that.
So it's like,
it's like pigs.
Pigs had been removed from the game animal category.
They're verbose.
It's like a cat.
It's like a coyote.
Their environments.
But I will say probably on those shows,
I guarantee they have to,
you know,
then that meat has to be used somewhere and taking,
taking a donated and process.
They can't just leave him lay.
I mean that's,
I don't think so,
but well,
dealing with 450 of them,
do they even have the resources to gather up all the are?
Because if they're shooting that many hogs and they're not doing anything with
it,
to me that's bullcrap.
Yeah,
they've got to have the resources.
Just like in New Zealand when they go in and call out the wild deer and that in
there,
because there's no predators,
they have the resources to go in with a chopper and pull it out and they,
they,
they harvest that meat.
So if they're shooting 450 pigs,
bastards better have a way to,
to keep that meat because that's ridiculous.
If they don't,
in my opinion,
my opinion.
Yeah.
I would.
I agree with you because it's a massive waste of great meat.
Wild pig is absolutely delicious.
It's really good for you.
It's completely different from domestic pig in the way it looks cause these
animals are eating all kinds of different natural things,
roots and and grasses and they're not just eating grain.
It's not like white.
It's not like a white meat.
Like that was the thing that they had this thing pork,
the other white meat.
I remember that.
That campaign,
if you ever see a wild pig folks,
it's not white.
It's not white at all.
It's just fucking red and it's not as red as a deer,
but it's a dark meat.
It's cause it's healthy.
We should,
we should invest in a barbecue house and just go in and put a barbecue house in
Texas and then just go kill all the wild pigs and use that to get all your meat.
Well that's what pig man does.
What he does that show he had called it was going to call it that stupid series
on this hemorrhage.
Here I go.
They had had kind of is like,
don't worry about it.
It's like,
you know,
the whole concept behind is cool,
but as just,
well,
it's a reality show.
They were,
they were doing that.
They were killing the hog and then go in and providing it to this.
Uh,
he had his own barbecue place,
which is a great idea,
but I don't think it's totally legal.
At least it might be a,
you can't sell wild game.
Like if I kill an elk,
I can't sell it,
which is a good thing.
Yeah.
But I,
I can donate it and I tell you the amount of traveling and hunting and I do,
I donate a lot of meat,
you know,
and a lot of,
a lot of different places.
Yeah.
I wouldn't want to do.
Yes,
but don't you think that like wild pigs,
if they became a revenue source like that,
if they had a restaurant that if they have an animal that is so completely
overpopulated and overran that they don't have any tag limits,
which pigs are at right now,
you could just go and shoot fucking pigs all day long and they'll,
there'll be happy for you,
including California,
which is like one of the most liberal states ever,
which has all sorts of crazy regulations on animals that need to be called an
aren't like,
there's real issues here with mountain lions and is the real issue with,
uh,
with people that don't want people to hunt mountain lines and they don't
understand how ridiculously overpopulated these fucking things are getting.
And these poor people that are running farms have to deal with these animals
coming in and just decimating there.
The population of their calves,
you know,
the,
the game animals,
like the people that will tell you about when mountain lion hunting was legal in
comparison now and then the deer population levels,
there's no comparison.
Right?
I mean there,
there's their fucking everywhere man.
And to hone ranch where I've been pig hunting before,
the guy who was our guide told us that he has a trail camera set up over this
waterhole and he got 16 different mountain lions on camera.
That's fucking crazy.
Danny.
Deer mountain lions can eat in a week one every couple of days.
It's unbelievable how many mountain lions they have.
And it's because you can't hunt them.
And that is when you have a Predator that can't,
you can't,
if we're going to be the stewards of the land,
which is what most people look,
if you were going to accept that we have regulations on game,
we have regulations on,
on,
you know,
fish that you can pull for the ocean.
We're supposed to be managing the population of these animals in a smart,
intelligent way.
And that's good conservation.
But when you remove some animals from that management,
simply because of public opinion,
not uninformed public opinion of people who are animal lovers,
that's ridiculous.
You can't do that.
That's,
that's contrary to the very nature of conservation in the first place.
Conservation isn't simply,
oh,
we need to preserve the habitat and give these animals food and make sure their
water is not polluted.
Sure.
That's most certainly a part of it.
And for people who don't know,
hunters had been responsible for way more money that goes to conserving wildlife
habitat,
conserving wetlands than any other group by far.
It's not even close.
No,
no.
Like tree hugger conservation group has come close to generating the amount of
money that has gone into conservation as hunters have.
But because you,
you're controlling populations of deer controlling populations of elk,
pigs,
all that's good.
But you've got to control fucking predators to Yup.
And they're realizing that now and a lot of these states where they reintroduced
wolves and people are fighting against people hunting wolves.
Like you better fucking go online and research those giant super packs of wolves
in Siberia that storm a farm and kill a hundred horses and no one could do a
goddamn thing about it because you've got a thousand wolves,
Gil.
Imagine being in a fucking farm and you're looking out the window and you see up
pack of wolves just tearing apart horses and no one could do anything about it.
Well that's what happens when shit gets out of line.
And that's the way wolves worked here.
You know,
they'll be generate those super pacs.
Here's a great story from World War One where the Russians and the Germans had a
ceasefire.
They were in there,
were in the woods in Russia.
They had a cease fire because so many of them were getting killed by wolves.
They would send out these packs.
They would send out rather these,
um,
these parties would like search parties at two,
two men at a time and they would never come back.
And they would go out and they'd find their clothes torn apart,
covered in blood,
and then they realize,
oh my God,
these guys are getting taken out by wolves.
They were getting targeted by wolves.
So when they would have small numbers,
these guys had rifles.
They were fucking soldiers and the wolves were eating them.
I mean,
and so stop talking about wolves.
The wolves are fucking scary dude.
Talking to a guy that spends a lot of time in the wild alone,
tell me next week,
next week I will be camping where there's a lot of wolves who by myself.
And it's like,
what are you going,
I'm not afraid of bears as much or mountain lions or anything.
Wolves scare the crap out of me,
you know,
walls and light day.
I don't know what it is,
but what is about wolves?
Because there's so much unknown about,
there's so much unknown about modern wolves.
We know about,
you know,
wolves of history old,
and in times like that when there were super pacs on that,
well,
they're just now being reintroduced and there's a whole new generation,
my generation included that we don't know.
We don't know and understand wolves and their,
how they hunt and how they,
you know,
how they are evolving.
And so to me there's just so much eerie about them,
you know,
so much unproven,
I could be that first guy that does get attacked and killed by a wolf.
You know that that's there because
there's more people now too.
So there,
there,
there's more of a chance of a wolf being conditioned to people or public than
there ever has been before.
So I think that it's just,
it's a different animal today than it was a hundred years go or 200 years ago.
And the thought of me,
you know,
me or a hunter or somewhere in there,
you get a pack that's just in the wrong mentality that maybe hasn't been hunted
that much or has it been pressured that much cause you're your way back in the
wilderness,
you know,
they may be a little bit more aggressive than,
than what you would like,
you know.
So they just kind of creep me out a little bit.
They should creep you out in the 14 hundreds of story called the the wolves of
Paris.
Have you ever heard?
No,
I haven't.
Yeah.
Wolves killed 40 people in Paris to the point where people had the track in the
city itself,
the Paris,
they'd killed 40 people.
And,
um,
it was that there was a Manny and wolf pack and a in 1450,
and the animals entered the city during the winter through breaches in its
walls.
This is so crazy.
And it's one,
uh,
they,
they had eventually a counter.
They had cornered the wolves and they were killing them with stones and spears
in front of the note.
Notre Dame cathedral.
That's a fucking crazy story.
That's like taking coyotes have today does his,
there's coyotes roaming around here.
Probably are someone and turn him into Wolf's if that's,
if that's a wolf in that environment.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
Well,
even scarier because there are obviously a lot bigger and creepier,
but people
throughout history have had real issues with wolves.
But today we associate wolves with being dogs.
We think of them as dogs.
Like anybody would hunt a wolf as an asshole.
What do you think the Little Red Riding Hood Story.
Why was that about a wolf?
Why is it the big bad wolf?
Why is,
why is the,
the three little pigs and the big bad wolf?
Because wolfs we're a fucking issue.
You'd go into the woods and the thing that you'd be worried about was wolves.
Yeah.
Do you want your kid not to be able to walk to school because there's wolf,
Roman,
the the area,
you know,
or whatever.
It's like dad,
I don't know.
But people don't want people hunting wolves.
It's one of the biggest blow backs.
Well,
it goes back to what you just said.
You know,
I said earlier,
and it's not exactly the same thing,
but you're like,
you don't care what lifestyle people lead as long as it doesn't affect you.
Same,
same concept here.
People don't give a crap about other stuff as long as it doesn't affect them.
So it's like they can we all we all fall into a little bit is we can be
hypocritical and say,
you know,
I don't like this and I don't like this and this because that's gonna Affect me.
But if somebody wants to,
if you know,
if they want to go out and do this,
that's fine.
I don't care.
You know?
So they look at it as,
well,
I guess.
I don't know where I'm going.
I just kind of lost that too.
Now it's like right there,
like the people that don't interact with those wolves don't hurt me.
Don't bother my kids walking to school.
So don't kill the wolves.
Well,
it's,
yeah,
but you know,
my kid might get pounced on by a mountain lion because we live in the rural
countryside,
you know?
Well,
not only that,
you had to keep,
their population is down for the health of all the other animals that are around
them as well.
They can start decimating wildlife populations.
They've done that with ALC.
They've done that with deer in the areas where they had been reintroduced.
The numbers of elk have drastically reset.
I'm from Idaho,
man.
I know that full,
full on the valley where I grew up.
I mean in,
in the late nineties early two thousands I mean elk,
elk,
it was El cutting heaven.
There was outcome and down in our eaten out of our cattle fear,
you know,
right at the back of mom and dad's house,
there was elk everywhere and the hunting was awesome and they weren't bothering
the crops or anything.
Well then the wolves come in.
Can you imagine?
Can you picture a herd of elk,
you know,
and all of a sudden there's,
oh,
there's a real big dog over there.
Well,
that's a big coyote.
The Coyote starts picking them off and it takes them quite a while before they
learn and condition themselves that,
hey,
that's not a coyote.
That's something different.
So those herds were just standing.
They were just,
it's like a Turkey shoot.
They ain't never,
never sprayed around walls.
No.
They'd experienced mountain lion or mountain lions,
coyotes and bears,
which don't hunt like wolves do.
They don't hunt in packs.
A pack of wolves comes in.
They think there's the damn coyotes again.
Whoa,
we're Jimmy.
Go,
what's going on here?
And the next thing you know,
it takes them years to condition themselves to her.
Now,
elk hunting today is different than it was 15 years ago because the elk act
differently.
I mean,
there's certain instances where it's similar,
but they're a different animal to hunt today than they were 20 years ago.
Have you ever been,
uh,
hunting in any way and had to kill and had to keep a Predator off the kill?
Eh,
so,
uh,
I was hunting deer whitetail deer actually in northern Idaho with a bow isn't in
like 2008,
2009,
something like that.
And I was filming the hunt,
you know,
this was before I started the TV show,
but at that time I already had had the concept of solo hunter in mind.
So I'm filming everything and it just delight,
like it's dark.
And so I go to take the camera off the,
the arm that I had and I flipped the switch and the camera down the bottom of
the tree crushed.
So I was like,
crap.
Well then a deer comes out.
I'm like,
well,
I'm going home tomorrow.
Anyway,
so I grabbed my bow,
thumped the deer,
and uh,
I'm sitting there in the deer,
kind of goes over and starts to do the wobble thing.
Well,
next thing you know,
a bear pulls out,
a black bear comes up and takes the deer down,
immediately,
pulls it over this hillside.
And I'm like,
that was pretty Dang cool.
I've wished.
And I was just,
I was more mad at myself than awestruck because I was like,
I dropped my damn camera out of the tree and I could have filmed that.
But um,
so I was more like just upset.
So I thought,
no big deal.
I'll just climb down,
go down,
spooked the bear off,
get my dear,
go home,
no big deal.
So I go on,
I'm trailing trailing this deer and all I've got is my flashlight in one hand
and my bow and the other and I can hear the bear sliding it down the the
hillside and it's a pretty steep grade and I'm like [inaudible] making noise,
doing whatever.
Cause I'd have experiences with bears and it didn't,
wasn't that big of a deal.
But then everything got quiet.
And then I was like,
and where I screwed up was I picked up the phone and called my wife,
hey babe,
I'm a trail and a dear.
I'll be home tomorrow.
What's going on?
I'm like,
oh this bear took it.
And I was like,
ah,
stupid.
Why would you say that?
Cause then from then on it was like,
and so from then on,
my wife's been freaked out about bears,
but,
so I'll finish the story.
But so I'm trailing often thisi super quiet and I'm like,
ah,
good.
The bear just kind of ran off.
I'm gonna go find my dear.
And I stood up on this,
uh,
this stump,
it was kind of a logged area.
I stood up on the stump and I'm looking around with this flashlight,
just kind of panning around,
looking for the deer and all sudden I hear her just kind of a noise.
I'm like,
I like this right at the base of that stump.
That bear was on top of that deer.
And he's just like,
he just huffed one time.
I just know far away from you.
Oh,
four,
five feet,
six feet.
I Dunno.
I mean,
it was close.
I'm standing on the stone and he's on this side,
on top of the deer.
So I just kinda jumped back and went back up.
I'm like,
what was I thinking going after a bear that just took down a deer that thinks
that's a deer?
He just hooked down so he's gonna be like defending,
defending it.
And I was like,
you stupid fool.
You could've just,
you could've just,
you could've been over right there.
So the next morning I go in no big deal.
Daylight,
the deer,
the bear doesn't have,
you know,
he's not,
it doesn't have a big a coneys during the day I guess.
But he just ran off.
I grabbed the deer and I have that on film.
Actually,
if you look at the,
the first solo hunter episode,
it's episode one on one.
It's got that where I kill a deer.
But then I do a flashback of the year before when I was filming that hunt and
I've got my little handycam that I filmed.
You can see all the scratches all over the,
the deer and you can see where the bear had eaten it out from the hind in and
all that kind of stuff.
How much of the bear the bear eat.
He had only eaten part of the hindquarters.
You know,
they always go in through the butthole and through the soft to soft tissue,
but he,
you could see where he had scratched it up and worried,
had drug it down and,
and uh,
just eight PARLA hindquarters.
But you know,
for the most part the deer fine,
salvageable.
So I just cut him up and took him home.
So when you,
when you have an animal like that,
the other animals eating part of it,
do you worry about it being contaminated in any way?
Is there any concern?
I didn't even think about it there.
I mean,
obviously you're cooking it above a certain temperature anyway,
but I didn't even think about that.
I don't,
I don't even know,
honestly,
if that could have been an issue,
you know,
with a bear eating,
eating the meat.
I don't know anybody out there know.
If I could've gotten sick,
I have troubles getting out of bed and you're going,
this is wrong with my eyeballs.
You,
uh,
cut out around the airway.
Yeah,
I cut all.
But you know,
it's just,
I dunno,
I didn't even think about that.
There was the rivets that I told you about the guys up in northern Canada,
they,
uh,
they shot a bear and it was getting dark and so they went back in the morning to
recover it.
And another larger bear was eating it while they got there.
And they're like,
oh great.
It's great.
That's a real issue up there.
Cannibalism,
cannibalism is standard and it's,
it's just gonna get worse.
You know,
he's a numbers increase,
has cared,
only get worse,
can't it?
I mean,
until they get an get disease or you know,
and have a die off because nature has a kind of a way of taking care of itself.
Maybe four man came along anyway.
There was how many millions of buffalo roaming the countryside.
And I'm sure there were areas where the disease or something was spread and
there was a die off.
And so the herds moved off and split off.
And that's how,
that's kind of how animals maybe maybe moved across the countryside is,
is different elements of nature that happened,
you know.
So we look at this is where like,
you know,
I'm on this earth for 80 90 years.
Hopefully.
Well that's,
that's nothing in evolution of animals or in the,
the how,
how a herd or a spore or certain species might evolve in an area,
you know,
and elk herd could grow up to a certain number and then it could have a die off
because of sickness.
They could grow again.
Well that might take a hundred years,
you know,
for that process to,
so for us to actually see that,
that population curve,
but then that's when you start talking about introducing the wolves.
That population curve takes a big dive quick.
But you know,
what was the logic behind reintroducing wolves?
Bureaucracy,
I guess.
I don't know.
Because wolves are cute and cuddly and they want them in Yellowstone because
it's a park.
But I'll,
there's no fences around Yellowstone.
I didn't know that.
Did you know that there's no fences around Yellowstone?
I mean grizzlies,
the next,
that next thing we got grizzlies in Idaho that are starting to cause issues.
And you know,
there's,
there's all kinds of instances in Montana and that grizzlies the next animal to,
to start causing issues I believe,
just because for some reason now it seems like
nature is at its prime for bear populations to grow.
You look at bare numbers,
hog numbers,
all these,
all these populations of animals numbers are continue to steadily grow
massively.
And I think that's just the,
the nay,
nay natural curve of where we're at that if we weren't involved in managing or
anything,
it had hit that precipice where diseases and cannibalism and all these things
would take over and nature would,
would curve itself back down to get sustainable numbers or they just out eat to
eat themselves out of home.
When you stumbled upon that bear and the bear was like four feet away from you
with the deer,
did you just back out of there?
I just backed away.
Yeah.
I was just like,
whoa.
Went back up and then,
uh,
slept in my truck that night.
And then the next morning I just kind of went around and I had my brought in my
gun and uh,
just a couple shots on the hillside.
The bear runs off you,
you get the deer d did you ever watch that show,
the hunt?
I did.
I watched one or two episodes of it.
And my problem is I look at it,
I'm ruined because as a producer I watch everything as a producer rather than as
a viewer.
And so it kind of,
I hate that because I can't ever watch something and get true entertainment out
of it are true value.
Well yeah,
I know what you mean.
But it was badly produced in my opinion.
I felt like,
first of all,
they kept using this fake bear sound,
the same sound over and over again.
They would interject it and you knew that they were interjecting it.
Cause all of a sudden like there'd be like a shaky camera and why is it bare
going to be growing and exact roaring?
A bear's going to be damn silent until he's ready to kill you.
And then they would do it over and over again.
Right before they cut to commercial.
So like to get you to like tune in,
look the camera shake and raw.
But you know what I guarantee everybody watching us like well bears make noise
in the wild not,
and that's the problem with shows.
Like you know like that,
that they're putting on the mainstream.
There was one called chase and tails on there for awhile on,
on a and e or one of those where it's like everybody associates hunters as
flannel wearing overweight,
middle aged,
bearded men.
You know,
and we're not,
we're businessmen were regular people or whatever.
You know,
you,
there's all these two types of people that are hunters and that her outdoorsman,
but society sees us as Bubba.
Well in movies too,
like it's portrayed marine movie,
they were assholes that poisoned.
The directors are asked there's and all that.
And I didn't know drugs.
They usually drunk,
you know,
and that's,
that's because it's the same,
same concept as,
you know,
Disney portrayed animals as people.
So we think of animals as people.
Well Mo,
Hollywood and whatever else portrays hunters as the dumbest.
Yeah,
the most simple minded.
Once reality,
you look at,
you look at the science and the management behind conservation and wildlife
conservation,
Eh,
it's not stupid stuff,
you know?
No,
he's not stupid stuff at all.
It's very calculated as contraceptives for deer.
That's stupid stuff.
Yeah.
That's birth control for deer.
That costs hundreds of thousands of dollars when dear delicious,
so they're running around instead of just having hunters come in and shoot them
with bows and arrows across crossbows,
whatever you can to control the population like that.
It would only take a couple of weekends and they could,
you know,
do big now and get a lot of meat out of it,
but instead they're going to spend hundreds of thousands of dollars and give
them birth control.
What do you think is the answer for people when what you mean,
what is it going to take for?
Have you ever,
if you've ever convinced somebody that hunting is okay?
Well,
I mean,
what's the answer?
What's,
what's the main thing?
How can we,
how can we educate people to where it's like,
you know,
hunting is not what,
what
you've been taught and what you think it is or what certain people say it is.
Well I tried to do it.
Well I don't,
I'm not trying to educate people,
but in discussing it and people listening to these discussions,
they kind of get a more nuanced balanced perspective.
And I know for a fact that there's a lot of people that post on my message board
that have talked about how they had one opinion of hunting before the podcast
and a completely different opinion of it now.
And they also never factored in the PA cracy of wearing leather,
having a leather couch,
leather seats in your car,
leather jacket,
and then complaining about hunting.
They don't,
there were disconnected.
And that disconnection is let us to be like spoiled little kids.
We don't understand where all this is coming from.
We don't have a direct interaction with the food itself.
And when you do have a direct interaction with the food itself,
when you've killed the animal yourself,
the whole process is a completely different thing.
I,
you know,
I'm eating an animal that I stalked,
shot,
butchered,
sliced up,
put into packages,
vacuum sealed it,
put it in my freezer,
thought it out,
cooked at eight it from a to z.
It's been in my hands and that's a completely different experience than 99% of
anyone who eats meat is ever going to have.
And I encourage people,
I think if you could do it,
if you have the time,
I think a lot of people don't know where to start.
That's one thing they don't.
Yeah,
I do.
I've got some friends right now.
There's three of them that are just starting,
starting out hunting.
Last year they killed their first year.
You know,
and it's,
it's funny to,
it's not,
I say funny,
it's,
it's interesting to see their di,
their evolution cause they're like searching youtube for everything.
They're like,
well how would you do this?
How'd you do that?
And I'm like,
I don't know.
I just do it.
They're like,
well they had to search on youtube to find out how to gut a deer.
And so they have this little video clip of him gutting this deer and did try to
take it all apart.
It's the funniest thing,
but it's like all these are grown men figuring it out on their own.
There's nobody out there to teach them.
There's no schools that are,
it's like,
hey,
you want to be a hunter?
Come to my school.
You don't pay tuition.
Do this.
And it's like if you want to learn,
it's got to be hands on.
It's got to,
you got to have a mentor.
You've got to have,
because I get emails like that all the time.
How do I get started?
How I live in,
I live in Arizona and I hunt these mountain ranges.
How do I find the deer?
Cause I spend countless hours trying to find deer.
How would you hunt this area?
I don't know.
I don't live there.
You'd have to,
there's a lot of information that we're asking for.
Two,
you'd have to go there.
You don't have to tell them how much do you know?
You don't have to explain to them what deer habitat is,
where they,
where they nest.
Where the bed rather.
And there's also,
it's interesting but it's sort of,
there's a comparison to be made for you learning how to use computer software to
edit video you just taught yourself.
Yeah,
I mean if you want to do it,
you just got to kind of figure it out and teach yourself.
And the cool thing about today is you can watch those youtube videos.
I mean in the back in the day,
what would you have done?
You've gotten a book or something and try to like look at the diagrams,
do what I did.
You start cutting bloody hands and started cutting stuff comes out and you can
fuck things up like that.
Just start cutting,
right?
You can mess yourself up.
And he'd get the tarsal glands all over the meat and smell like shit.
And you know,
there's a lot of people that ruin meet because they don't understand the proper
preparation and how to take care of it once they actually kill an animal.
Oh yeah.
There's a,
there's a lot to it and I think talking about it is real good.
I think it's important to have guys like you on and Rinella and Cameron Hanes
and Jim Shockey when it comes on TV.
So people get an understanding of who these people are that actually are
hunters,
that they're not those flannel shirt wearing yokels that you see in these really
cartoonish and character,
uh,
you know,
character,
richer,
richer.
That's the word Kutcher,
caricature character at your,
why am I saying turrets or caricature?
The caricature is of of hunters.
These cartoonish shitheads I think,
yeah,
I think you're smart by having somebody like Shockey because he's,
uh,
he's at a different,
he's a different person than me or Steve or Remy or,
or Cameron,
you know,
we're,
we're different than what he is.
He's something special in that even if you took that man outside of the hunting
industry and put him into something else,
if he was an oil man,
or say if he was a cattle man or whatever,
he's got a personality about him and philosophical way of speaking and knowledge
about him,
that he's gonna educate people just based off of what he knows and how he's
going to say something.
He,
and I could say the exact same things,
but the way he says it,
you're going to be like,
damn,
I get that.
But I say it.
You're gonna be like,
that guy's a fool.
You know,
you a little hard on yourself.
Well,
I'm just saying,
I'm trying to build up Shockey here.
I mean,
I know the guy needs every bit of it.
He can get it right.
You know,
guys like me,
we got it up.
I was like,
no,
but I'm saying is I'm glad you're having him and I'm going to,
it's definitely a podcast I'm going to be tuning into because I like his
philosophy behind not only hunting,
but life and also behind,
you know,
family and everything else I do is I think he's,
I think he's a great person for that,
you know?
And I think it's getting,
I think that's the type of person that for broad society is your spokesperson.
Well,
I feel like that is a great one as well because he's so well read.
He's a great writer and z educated,
super educated in a guy who really,
truly cares about environment.
It's really truly cares about hunting.
Really truly cares about conservation.
And he said,
God,
it's in fucking fantastic shape.
I went hunting with him and the one thing that I was blown away with is how
physically demanding hunting is like hiking.
I looked at hiking and like that's for fucking,
people don't really work out bunch of pussies but uphill.
It's fucking hard man.
Especially when you're holding a rifle so you're not swinging your arms and get
a pack on like you get exhausted quick.
Did you have to pack your deer out or was it like in an area where you didn't
have to break it down and put it in your pack?
Uh,
what do you mean your dear?
When you hunted in Montana,
did you have to break it down a,
pack it out on your back?
Yeah,
we will.
There's three of us.
It was me,
Callen and Rinella.
So my friend Brian Count.
So when we went to get my dear,
we had it,
we shot it that night.
Got It.
Took the liver and the heart cooked that that night and then put it up in a
tree.
We hung them in the juniper tree.
So we went there to get it in the morning because it was kind of late and uh,
we had seen some mountain line shit in the area.
It was kind of disconcerting.
He's big ropey shit filled with mountain lions have been hunted in that area so
they probably wouldn't even come close to you.
So yeah.
Yeah.
Good.
I don't want,
I don't like those fucking things.
I've seen two mountain lions.
And how do you hear it while you're California again?
Never shot one.
I lived in Colorado.
You did?
I saw the picture on you.
On all social media.
I can't with hand bells.
Yeah.
That's so silly.
My Toki often strangle it.
My own sister asked me if I killed him.
Outline.
Really?
Yeah.
I'm like,
what the fuck do you think killed him?
Outline with a belt.
You kidding me?
Kill a house.
Cat with a belt.
Try to get a house cat.
Hold on to that fucker and killed with a belt.
I think will scratch your eyes out.
Yeah.
It's 150 pound house cat.
Are you fucking crazy?
Oh,
I've seen too.
I saw one in Colorado.
Uh,
really briefly.
It's like both of them been about the same size,
like 60,
70 pounds,
like dog size and the other one I saw in Monosito,
which is like a residential area and Santa Barbara.
I was driving on the street.
We saw this thing run across the street and the first we thought it was a
coyote.
Then I saw the tail is tails like boom,
bobbing around.
I'm like,
Oh shit,
that's a cat.
And it had a more of a bouncy way.
Like coyotes have that sort of stiff.
Yeah.
Fucking crease.
Scared to death.
Shitty way of running.
Never seen a coyote sleep.
No.
That's cause they don't that you're used to getting shot at and chase down.
You can imagine being a coyote.
That's like the worst life ever.
It's a sucky life.
Other than like a rabbit.
I'd rather be a rabbit than a coyote from real people have rabbits for pets.
Yeah,
yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
They're dirty,
stinky fucking little animals.
I got a coyote,
a cushion at home,
like a pillow that's covered in coyote skin.
It's gross.
It's like sleep.
My wife bought it.
It's not mine.
She's like,
I like she,
she ordered like a couple different kinds of animal skins that were converted in
the pillows and for whatever reason she hates coyote.
So for whatever reason,
she got a coyote one.
She's like,
Babe,
I brought home this,
uh,
this animal skin couch that's a sheep of pay.
She turned,
we have chickens,
we have a 24 chickens.
So we have this a fenced in area where the coyotes are trying to figure out how
to get to the chicken.
So we'll find them near our backyard all the time.
And she loves these chickens.
She takes care of them.
So she particularly hates coyotes because they're always trying to figure out a
way to sneak in,
you know,
and they've killed dogs in our neighborhood before,
they'll,
they'll snatch one off a leash.
I have a friend who lives in Brentwood,
which is another residential area,
and his neighbor was walking her dog.
She had like a little dog walking.
She heard click,
click,
click.
She knowed.
It was thought it was like a dog,
you know,
behind her.
And the coyote just ran up,
snatched a dog right off of her fucking leash and ran.
That's a hungry dog.
That's a hungry Kyle.
Yeah.
It was running away with her dog.
Like the dog was just trying to,
and she's screaming and the leash is being dragged behind.
It's just running with her dog.
A sad,
sad and weird.
It's weird that this,
those creepy predators are wandering around and it just decided to bust a move.
Like this is the time.
Yeah.
Kyle,
did you really?
Yeah,
yeah,
I was uh,
I don't know a lot of fucking,
no,
11th grade.
Hello?
Yeah,
it was,
it was a long time ago,
but I was doing the dishes and look outside.
I was about five o'clock in the afternoon and,
and looking,
we lived in a trailer park,
so the trailer next door,
there was a,
it was a Kyle underneath,
underneath there just batting around,
playing around with some toys and all kinds of balls and stuff.
So I get out and I had a 22 to go around the back side and I see him and he
jumped up at the clothes on the clothes line and I rifled like two or three Adam
and I missed,
he ran straight into the woods.
I went back in,
I had a freaking rabbit call,
like a distress call.
Oh,
I,
yeah.
I shot back probably 200 yards and I got up against the tree and I started
blowing that fricking thing and sure shit that then came running right at me and
he backed me up against the tree and I lift my foot up and he latched right onto
my boot and I shot him point blank and I emptied out the whole,
the whole entire clip.
Yeah.
And it think smelled like skunk really bad.
But yeah,
enables,
scares a lot of hair missing off of it.
But though it was weird because that week before I had a two,
two little doxins in the family and I light,
we used to let him outside,
no leash,
they go take a shit,
come back.
Only one came back.
And,
uh,
we think there may be,
you know,
he made it took him most likely,
right?
Yeah.
We never got a bass week
in silicone valley,
a mountain line,
viciously mall.
The six year old boy,
some kid was hiking with his parents and,
uh,
the,
the kid was behind them in a mountain line,
came up behind a tack.
The kid,
the parents yelled at it and screamed and chased after the mountain lion and
just like tried to hit it and it dropped the kid and ran off.
But the kid got fucked up.
I heard that they scared it away.
But uh,
so then they,
uh,
set hunters loose on this,
a cat and dogs and everything like that.
And they,
you know,
this is another,
the,
another issue that they have with mountain lions in California cause they're not
hunting them.
Yeah.
That's crazy.
Yeah,
it is crazy.
And it's crazy how people have this idea that there are these beautiful things
and they are beautiful.
They're there,
they're interesting.
They're fascinating.
But you got to keep those fuckers the check,
you know?
And that's a real issue with people that don't understand law of wildlife.
They just have these liberal points of view that's based on no reasoning,
no logic,
not a balanced perspective,
no real true understanding of wildlife there.
Understanding he's just based on what they think is awry with they think is,
see it,
leave them alone.
There's natural animals.
Yeah.
And then you go hiking and you're going to get eaten.
You fuck.
Do you understand that?
They're big giant monsters.
Yeah.
If those were Werewolf's,
you would be sending packs of fucking military people in the woods to try to
kill the Werewolf while mountain lions way fucking scary than a werewolf.
Cause it's not just a mountain line.
One day out of the month.
Okay.
The wolf man turns into the wolf man and the full moon comes out.
Mountain lions wake up every morning,
a mountain lion,
a mountain lion kill something,
and they killed big things with their face.
They're used to killing deer and elk and shit that runs really fast and they
kill it with their face and you're,
you're content with those things wandering around because they just look
beautiful.
That's ridiculous.
I'm not saying that we should wipe them off the face of the earth,
but we should come really close.
There should be like four or less.
You have four left Hoffman,
all of Houma we radio tagged yet leave him with Oklahoma with tags on that.
We,
we have a fucking a group of scientists that are monitoring their uh,
their progress on a screen and whenever they come anywhere near a person,
suddenly the hunters,
I think hunters would be glad to take the place of the mountain lions and
keeping the population in check.
Yes.
And eat that meat and you know,
use it for people.
I'm on team people,
you know,
I like people t man,
team human.
Yes,
right?
Like people way better than other animals.
I think animals are amazing.
People are way better.
You can talk to them.
They make you laugh,
you hang out with them.
There are species you breed with them.
They live in your neighborhood.
I mean,
it's fucking ridiculous.
That is with animals.
You can't though.
You can't.
You can read them,
but you can't.
Even if you fuck him,
nothing happens other than you get happy.
I promised my wife I keep everything straight.
Impossible on this show.
No,
I did.
I told Mark Mark,
I'm like,
mark,
you know when we get to talk and I have a tendency to dip a little bit,
I'm like,
you need to keep me on that level playing.
Don't let me go.
Let me do what
I like.
Good humor.
Typically get Rah Rah worried about your,
your perception,
the perception of people.
No,
no.
I'm not worried about my perception of people because uh,
you know,
people are gonna think of you.
What they,
what they do.
Right.
You know,
but I,
I'm,
I worried about me.
You know,
I,
I have a perception of myself that I,
that I like to maintain,
which is,
which has been and I believe is,
is it is what it is.
You know,
when you meet me face to face,
it's the exact same as when you meet me anywhere else.
God from that show.
The same guy from your show.
Yeah.
I think,
yeah,
I think I'm more of a bad ass in real life than I am on the show.
Honestly.
I watched back to the editing,
you know,
like I'm combing through some of the footage I just filmed last week.
I'm like,
man,
I got my guts hanging over my belt and I'm like,
I'm talk.
I slurred over it,
my voice and everything and I'm like,
I just don't look tough,
you know?
And I'm like,
I'm tough.
Whenever you say like that,
it's tough to convince me.
No,
I don't have that,
you know?
I don't have that deep raspy voice and stuff.
So it's like,
you know,
yeah,
we're all,
we're all tough.
We're in our own mind.
You know,
you don't have to project it.
That's,
everybody thinks they do.
But when you try,
if you tried it,
if you try to create your brand and who you are and what you think you want
people to think of you as,
you're just going to be a doof Douche bag.
It's got to be yourself.
Yeah.
I like how you went with Duke,
but I know what you were trying to keep that even plan.
It's a Douche bag.
Cause I did post a picture today,
you know,
last night of the had the word Douche bag in it.
And you I felt yeah I got in trouble.
No,
I just kind of second thought it a little bit.
I'm like,
I just posted,
I should,
I have done that.
You know?
And it's like what's wrong with Douche bag?
Cause it's really how I feel,
you know?
That's really how I felt about the man.
So it's like who was the Douche bag?
What was it about?
I think it's fun in our country,
you know,
so bottles,
it was a bumper sticker on his truck.
It said it had to had a Douche bag with the Obama,
with the president's emblem as the,
Oh and then underneath that the guy was selling his truck.
So he had written his soap for sale.
So I just,
I'm like,
oh that's pretty cool.
Douche bag for sale.
Click.
And so I,
I post this,
not even thinking,
I was like,
oh it's the CIA.
Gonna come after because I've seen stuff that guys post or whatever,
they're like,
it's shut down my Facebook page or whatever.
And it's like they can do that and it's so weird.
Can
criticize the president too harshly or if there's any threat whatsoever of
violence,
like I'm going to kick the president's ass.
They'll come.
They should too though.
You know what they should but so I,
cause you know,
I'm a nice guy,
I'm on the outward side.
I'm a nice
guy at home.
I'm a nice guy,
whatever,
but I'm a Badass on the mountain.
I'll tell you that.
I see what you're saying.
The second amendment is a,
is a funny issue when it comes to Obama because there was this,
uh,
the head,
this recording of him doing this speech and talking about guns and he was
talking about how people want to keep their guns.
They'll never,
they're never going to let you take the guns.
And I'm like,
what a weird thing.
It is where people,
representative government,
where where people are elected,
they get into a position of power and then they look at people and they say
things like,
they're never going to let you take their gun.
They're going to like,
why would you,
why do you,
what are you trying to do?
Like why are you trying to take their guns if you're just a person and what you
are as a president.
Yes.
Through the leader of the country.
Yes,
we were the commander in chief and all that.
But essentially you're just a person.
So if you're a person,
why are you trying to take away other people's guns?
Do you think that people shouldn't have guns because they're all dangerous?
Because statistically that's a real tough argument matter to people like that.
I know they don't care.
Well,
that's why those people are ridiculous in anybody in that sort of a position
that has that sort of a point of view like you,
if you're going to be the fucking president of United States,
you gotta be able to back up everything you say with logic and science.
And if you look at the amount of people we have in this country,
there's 350 million motherfuckers in this country,
okay?
Not all of them are motherfuckers,
but some of them good and bad.
350 million people in this country,
there's probably 350 million guns.
Half of them are going on.
Statistically
speaking,
half of them are gun.
Probably.
Then look at how many people are actually getting killed by guns.
The number is ridiculously low,
which means that most people are really good at controlling themselves.
Most people have cars and they don't just drive into crowds of people,
but some people occasionally do.
If enough people do that,
are we going to take away cars?
The thing of it is is like you could have those people,
he's sitting here across from you and you can be explaining to them and you can
have the statistical data and you can have the proof and the facts and
everything.
They're still not going to care.
They don't care because there's more to it than just doing what's right and
doing what is statistically fact.
It's,
there's always a,
an agenda behind it.
There's something that they want to push well as a control as it did and they
just want to control people or,
or what is it?
Who knows?
But when you look at everything that like,
like the government is doing and even small things of something as simple as
giving out 12,000 bay and as to the police force,
what are you trying to do?
Create your own,
your own army.
Are you waiting for a civil war?
I mean,
what's,
what's going on here?
Why are you buying?
Yeah,
they provided the armies or the local police,
local police and I,
and I,
you know,
I'm probably speaking out of turn here because I don't know all the facts,
wherever,
but it's like 12,000 bayonet,
what do you need?
A bayonet four anyway,
this isn't,
this isn't the world war.
[inaudible] nom,
whatever.
Yeah.
But then it's like,
well,
you bought how many millions of rounds of ammunition,
you know,
so it's like,
well there's all the conspiracy theories and all that kind of thing,
but you sit back and you think,
you're like,
why are they doing that?
You know what?
What's going on here?
What are they trying to create or what are they,
why did they decimate,
you know,
the military,
why did they fire all these commanders that,
that,
that did such a bad ass job of taking,
taking out the bad guy,
you know?
Why did you pull out of Iraq?
Why did you all these,
there's,
there's always something more to it than just fact and data and numbers and
what's right and what's wrong.
There's,
it's,
it's man,
there's power hunger or something to it.
There's a lot of public or something freaky about it.
I don't,
there's something sick going on that I don't get in what way?
It just,
nothing makes sense.
Wouldn't you think that if you're the,
if you're the leader of,
of the country,
you would do things that the majority of people would think make sense?
Like what?
What does it make sense to you?
I think what doesn't make sense to me is pushing,
like say take the immigration issue.
I heard a statistic the other day,
whether it's right or wrong,
that 9 million people in the greater la area,
potentially half of them illegal.
There's more than 9 million people here.
Right?
And there's like the greater la city area.
So it was a smaller,
whatever it was.
They,
they the number 9 million they said,
they said potentially there's,
there's ha up to half of those are illegal,
not document it.
Which to me is like,
well that's one city,
but why would they allow the people to come across the border just so openly and
now it's like as a parent,
I have a kid in school and if they're putting these people in,
busing them all across the country and letting these people go in school without
even asking their ages or having to go through medical checks like my kids do or
any of those types of things,
it's like,
what's the reasoning behind that?
It's not a humanitarian,
you
know,
if you were a monetary and you'd block the block the damn border off and not let
people come across and experience all that,
you know,
suffering.
But then as me as the humanitarian little bit of humanitarian that I have in me,
it's like,
man,
if I'm in that position,
I'm coming across the border too and I'm working here.
You know,
I'm providing my family with a better situation.
But as a government,
uh,
managing government,
managing a country,
to me it just doesn't make sense that she would allow open borders.
Well,
I don't think it's totally open.
I mean,
it's difficult to get over here.
They risked their lives.
It's very tough and I know what you're saying,
but I also think that politically it's,
if you want democratic votes,
um,
the more lenient you are towards people come across this border,
the more lenient you are towards illegals.
Latino's,
giving them rights,
giving them education,
giving them the ability to drive cars or maybe even possibly vote.
That's going to be very advantageous.
If you're a Democrat,
if you're a liberal,
and if that's what your agenda is.
That's what we're trying to pursue.
It's interesting in republican circles,
Cubans are almost all Republican.
I mean there's a massive,
not all obviously,
but like Miami has a large population of very conservative Latino's.
It's a completely different sort of environment,
very republican,
very conservative.
It's a,
it's a completely different setup.
Then they have with uh,
Latinos or Mexicans in La and a lot of it is to do with what they've experienced
in Cuba and you know,
how the hardships that they encountered in a communist land and coming over to
America and realizing the opportunities and what,
what you can accomplish here and what's going on with Americans and Mexico.
The disparity between California and Mexico is so vast and the distance is so
small that it creates,
it's really weird environment where like I was in San Diego a couple of weeks
ago when I was joking around about how nice everybody is in San Diego and one of
the reasons why they're so nice cause you can walk to a third world country.
Like they know how good they got it.
If you want to get confused,
you want to think that uh hey man,
the world's all shit.
No,
no,
no.
You're in fucking San Diego.
Dude.
This is awesome.
Why don't let's go for a walk.
You and I are going to,
it will take us about an hour.
We'll BMT Awana and then you're going to see something that's not good.
You're going to see this is what happens when you don't have taxes and the
United States government and this the school system that we have.
This is what these people are trying to escape and as a human being,
when I go there and I see that environment,
I want to,
I want to say,
hey,
yeah,
they should be able to do whatever the fuck they want.
They should be able to come over here,
but they also should be able to figure out how to,
someone should engineer that society better.
Someone should figure out how to make that culture at least as accessible or as
advantageous as the American culture.
I Dunno,
and I think that's where I'm talking where it is.
They should be doing that rather than just saying,
well,
if you can't have it there,
come here and do it here then.
Yeah.
For the individual
plants in Mexico to it as an individual.
Yeah.
I'm doing exactly what they're doing.
Awesome.
Work in and I'm doing whatever I can to provide for my family and we know an
interact,
you know they're in Reno.
I know,
and interact with a lot of people that with within some of the churches and
stuff where it's like they've,
they've come here to better their lives and you can't hold them.
You can't.
It's hard to look at them and say,
well,
yeah,
but she broke the law so you've got to go back.
Right.
You can't do that.
No,
because you want as a whole,
you want people to have what I have.
You want people to be able to succeed.
It just sucks that their country doesn't see that.
You know what?
It hasn't done that.
But does that mean that our country has to be,
have liberal open Paul are relatively open policies where they're like,
if you don't have it there,
come here,
we'll give it to you.
But dude,
we still,
they don't really say that though.
I mean you do have to go through the border and it's fucking hard.
It's not easy to get from Mexico,
but not as hard as it used to be.
Really?
Yeah.
I don't know.
I mean,
I'm a guy that spends a lot of time in the wild.
I could probably,
I could,
I,
I'm not going to say that I could get across the border,
but kids,
well you,
women,
women and children and people are getting across.
They're getting across and it's got gotta be hard.
It's got to be difficult and difficult.
And some of the stuff that,
some of those kids,
you know,
have gone through that as devastating and it's just,
it's,
it's discussing,
you wouldn't want to ever have to have your family have to go through that
process.
So we're a nation of immigrants.
This whole nation was started by people who came from someone who didn't like
and decided to try to make a better world here.
And at what point does that get closed off and who?
Who is that available to you don't ever close it off,
I don't think.
But it's hard for people that come from Mexico to like legally immigrate to
America.
It's very difficult.
They make it hard and you have to have some reason why they should have you
here.
If you're a scholar and you're coming from Norway,
it takes time.
You know,
you have to go through all sorts of check points.
There's a lot of,
a lot of things have to happen.
I've,
I've had friends from Canada that wanted to get green cards to it,
to work in America and you know,
white people that speak perfect English,
that are well educated and it's hard.
It's not that easy to get a green card.
I'm just glad that I produce outdoor television and I don't have to deal with
it,
you know,
I don't have to do it,
or manage it or that kind of thing.
Obviously we all deal with it in wherever we live in that,
but it's also,
it's weird when you've got half the population's illegal,
what do you want to make half the viva criminals like can,
there should be some sort of a way that they can,
you know,
contribute as well because a lot of them are not paying taxes,
so it's even,
it's more advantageous to make them citizens didn't reg and do that for
[inaudible] for how many million?
9 million or something.
And they said,
okay,
Amnesty,
everybody that's here.
Yeah,
I believe they did a rake and I thought it was Reagan.
I'm not a bad thing and I'm just going on what I hear off the radio,
you know,
I'm just the uneducated white hunter guy,
you know Bubba,
but it's like,
you know,
they,
they did that at one time and now it's built up where there,
there's almost no way around it that they're going to have to do it again.
And unless they are,
they're stop measures to keep it from happening again.
That's going to be 2030 years down the road.
It'll happen again.
It's a compassion issue in a lot of ways because when people are in an
undeniably shitty environment,
like you know,
Juarez,
Mexico,
and they want to get out and they see San Antonio's right over there and
everybody's doing the same thing,
I would say same thing.
Yeah.
It's the real issue is like,
why are borders there?
What?
Why are,
why are nations there?
What is,
it gets real tricky.
It gets,
it's a very complex issue.
I'm going to keep hunting.
I'm just going to keep doing what I do.
Yeah.
I'm not even a tri pod cast.
I'm just going to do what I do.
When you're on top of a mountain with just a camera and a rifle,
how many cameras do you take when you go do that?
You know,
I used to take several,
now I just take one main camera,
which I use a DSLR camera that'll take stills and video and then I have one
Gopro,
but any more I find that I don't use the Gopro hardly ever.
The only,
the remain reason I'm using the Gopro now is because I had so many people
calling bs on me.
They're like,
there's no way you're filming that.
You've got a camera man,
whatever.
I'm like,
I'll show you.
So I mounted a thing off the back of my camera on my main camera that has just
basically a stick that I have a Gopro on.
So you can see me,
I mean there's,
there's a distance in one of the episodes that was on this year where you see
me,
you like fumbling,
I have to take a lens off.
I put another one on,
I spin the camera in the Gopro.
You can see the elk coming up.
Then you see me reach up,
focusing at turning it,
clipping onto the bow and then shooting it.
You know,
like it,
everything happens just that fast and it's like there take that stick in your
ear.
You know,
I filled this all myself and,
but it's,
it's become kind of a personal challenge that way where it's like,
yeah,
it can be done and,
and it adds more of a challenge to the hunt.
And to me it's,
it's in a case like that,
I didn't get nervous about making the shot on the elk.
I just drew back.
I didn't even range.
It drew back naturally,
just boom.
And the same thing happened with a deer that year.
Same thing,
drew back,
boom.
Because my brain was on the cameras.
My mind was on what I had to do with the cameras to get everything right.
And so hunt mode was natural because I'm,
I'm a natural hunter.
I grew up as a hunter from the time I was a kid.
So that,
that motion just to go over.
Whereas if the cameras weren't there and I'm just thinking and I have time to
wash that elk come up when I'm clipping on and I'm like,
okay,
where am I going to shoot him?
And I'm trying to range him and get a distance.
And you're trying to do all these things that you're supposed to do as a hundred
and then it's in your head that,
that,
that you've got to do all this.
And so when you anchor back your mind,
it might not be right.
You might be nervous.
I might be shaking cause there's been times where,
I mean else coming in,
I'm literally just shaken,
whether it's an elk or a deer and I'm just physically just,
I can't control,
like it's almost like a fear adrenaline.
Holy Crap,
this is happening.
Whatever.
I mean I remember as a kid sitting in a tree stand for elk and to the guys that
taught me how to bow hunt,
I was 13 years old and they're like,
yeah,
the best way.
Just go get in this stand and just wait for the elk to come into the waterhole.
Well shoot,
I'm a 13 year old kid up there by myself and you hear this herd of elk coming
in,
so you have 50 you know,
800 to a thousand pound animals coming in,
screaming,
chasing each other and,
and just,
you just freeze.
And I see,
I was shaking so bad that that platform on the standards,
like I was like,
man,
hold it together man.
You know?
And it's like that's what you get when animal comes in.
And I don't know what,
what gives you that adrenaline rush?
Is it the fact that you know you can kill it?
I don't think so.
I think it's just the fact that this wild animals getting close,
you know,
something anticipation.
There's so many factors.
Same thing when you go,
you know,
you're getting off the ski lift and you,
you,
you know,
you strap on the snowboard and you know you're going to go off this,
this one run that's you just looked at as you're coming up the hill,
you're like,
I'm going down that.
And then you get there and you're like,
holy crap,
this is scary,
man.
I don't know if I want to do this or not.
But I think it's that feeling.
It's like things more so even I get more out of it because that's more me,
you know,
I get more of a thrill out of elk and it's,
hunting and golf,
that's kind of my two things outside of family.
And it's like,
I get excited over that.
You know,
you hit,
you hit just a,
just a killer iron and you're just watching that thing fall and it's just kind
of cutting into there and you're like,
you get that feeling a little bit that could go in the hole.
You know where that's going to get close.
That's kind of the same thing.
But with hunting it's like that much more amplified because it's a live thing,
you know,
it's a live event and you don't have any control over that.
That all could come in and do whatever.
Yeah.
Anticipation and build up for one moment.
And also the amount of work involved in getting up there and it's like all for
this one moment.
Ready?
Don't fuck it up.
But what people don't see too is on TV.
You know,
I posted a comment on Instagram either he was like,
you know,
for you guys as information hunting's not as easy as it looks on social media
and on television,
you know,
which to me is a simple comment,
but people are like,
oh,
that's so true.
Blah blah,
blah,
blah.
It's like,
well,
I might be on the mountain for nine days.
Not seeing an animal.
Like I'm that Moose Hunt.
I saw one moose before I shot my moose.
So you're there for 10 12 days not seeing anything all sudden there's the most
bang,
whoa crap that just happened,
you know?
I was like,
wow.
So that's hunting.
That's reality of it.
Whereas on TV you see six,
eight minutes of me traveling those,
I think he killed a moose.
That's awesome.
You know that Moose show was wild,
the one where you shot the Moose and then it started floating down the river?
Yeah.
It wasn't in the room,
but yeah,
he was just,
he was in the,
the marsh.
So where he was standing,
it was like knee deep and then he kind of went back in the willows and so I had
to actually go in the willows and pull him out because the boat,
we tied him onto the boat and tried to get the boat to pull him out,
but it wasn't happening.
So I had to go in and filled my waders.
I'm just tugging on it when,
what's on the video and I put the Gopro on my head and I'm just,
I had to just basically just leverage and get this moose broke out of the
willows to where the water was deep enough.
Word to float.
And I don't know how I did it physically.
I don't know how much does it weigh?
Oh that's 12 1400 pound animal.
That's a big damn 14 and a hundred pounds.
I don't know how I did it.
It had to been adrenaline because the moment we got him and tethered to the boat
and float over the sandbar,
I would,
people don't realize I was closer to death right then on any than any other hunt
I've ever been on.
I was so hypothermic that I had to get off the boat and I literally just took
all my clothes off and just piled on one dry coat that I had and,
and uh,
a pair of pants and I ran up and down the sand belt bar back and forth cause it
started out like kind of a hunched over little little trudge.
And it,
it took me about 40 minutes before I generated enough body heat to get myself
out of the hyperthermic state because I was so,
I was so cold because I was so excited about the moose that I just jumped in and
I'm like,
yeah,
look up my most,
whatever.
My waders filled up everything and you're in water that's,
you know,
just comes off of the glaciers up there.
Probably 34,
35 degree water,
maybe,
maybe a little warmer.
I don't know.
I didn't have a thermometer,
but it's damn cold.
So it just got me so close to the point where my body was starting to just
really get crazy and I was not thinking right.
The only thing that I could think of because everything was so wet was just to
run.
And so I just ran up and down the sand just back and forth and back by herself.
No,
I had that one guy.
Wow.
That's scary as fuck man.
Hypothermia kills a lot of people.
It's a lot of folks don't know killer.
Yeah.
You get to the point.
That's why I tell people I'm like,
it's a lot easier to stay warm than to get warm.
So if you start to feel a chill,
put a coat on,
you know,
don't get yourself.
Well.
The other thing about hard hiking too,
when you're hooking it up the mountains,
as you start sweating,
that's why wool so important.
People don't,
um,
many people who don't go into those environments and don't understand like how
you can start sweating when it's really cold out.
Don't know how great wolves,
yeah,
wolves.
Awesome.
I like,
there's some great synthetics out there to the wick.
The moisture away from your body,
like will say,
well,
I like,
you know,
I grew up as a wool guy.
Everything was all,
Whoa,
whoa,
whoa.
Well,
a lot of synthetics.
They'll pull it away from your body and then they'll drive fast.
Real wool is gonna pull it away from your body.
And the cool thing about wool is even when it's wet,
it's going to keep you warm,
but it doesn't try real fast.
Whereas the synthetics,
synthetics a pull it away but then they'll dry fast too.
Why is it dry faster?
Just to,
it's just the fiber.
Just the fabric.
I don't think it holds the moisture as as well,
but it pulls it away.
It's like a more closed off wool is still amazing because if you can't get dry
we'll still going to keep you warm.
Yeah.
Isn't that crazy?
Yeah,
but it's heavy and bulky on the,
I don't know.
There's,
there's some good stuff you guys mentioned firstlight there.
That's some amazing stuff.
But you know,
I've grown to two were probably about 10 years ago I moved away from wool and
into synthetics just cause they,
the technology was there,
there was started getting better and then cause it's lighter.
Yeah.
Now I'm with under Armour so it's obviously an underarm or leaving them.
They've got some clothing that we prototyped this last fall that was a kind of a
wool acrylic blend that was pretty amazing.
Pretty good stuff.
So really,
but we'll a clear acrylic blends.
Yeah,
we just announced,
yeah.
It's not necessarily it's similar texture and feel to,
to the wool,
but you know,
you combine that with some of the synthetic base layers in that and it's,
you've just got a really hearty,
durable fabric that can be replicated and printed on and all kinds of different
things.
But that's a consideration that you have to really plan out,
right?
Like how much weight you're carrying.
Like what,
how much stuff do you actually need?
You take,
you take what you need and uh,
that's it.
I mean,
there's no reason to take any comfort.
that's one of the things that I,
that I probably should be better at.
Like I hate sleeping on the ground when I,
when I hunt,
I'm miserable.
Like at night I,
I basically just roll from one side of the Eczema side the next,
because I can't sleep because I'm like not taking that two pound pad.
I'm going to take it,
take the 16 ounce pad instead,
you know,
thinking one pound wall.
It's like,
you know,
on,
I've got seven pounds around my stomach that I,
that I'm carrying around that I shouldn't be carrying around either.
Right?
But we all get so caught up into the weight that you know,
you,
you kind of neglect certain things and that's important when you're going on a
back country pack trip where you're going to be in several days in that weight
weight's a big deal because when you start hiking up a mountain,
you're just thinking,
I mean,
I know I do.
I'm thinking in my mind,
what can I have left out of my pack?
You know what could have made this trip lighter?
Because if you don't have a pack,
it's a lot easier to get up the mountain,
but you gotta be comfortable or you're going to hike your butt back off the
mountain to wear like a lightweight boot too.
I do.
I'm a light.
I'm super lightweight,
boot all the time.
Even in rugged country.
I like a really lightweight boot.
I've never,
I'm the kind of guy,
I've never sprained an ankle,
never,
never had any knee or an ankle issues.
I've had knee issues,
but that really doesn't have anything to do with the boot.
But it's like,
I like lightweight.
I like maneuverability and just,
I feel more,
feel more mobile.
I don't like the big heavy rock mountain boots,
you know?
And I've,
I've worn them unlock,
but they're just rigid and I just feel like my legs get tired and I just can't
move.
But when I have a light boot that's more like a sneaker,
I don't think my legs get as tired and I can just,
yeah,
that's what I'm thinking because I'm going,
I'm a hunting in Alaska first week of October and uh,
I had these,
uh,
these heavy schnee's could boot great heavy boots.
They're real,
they're excellent,
waterproof and were like that.
But man,
I went hiking with them recently,
trying to break them in.
I'm like,
my fucking legs tried to Ryan leather when it's rain in a bunch too.
I mean,
it's,
it's hard,
but that,
that boot is made for that environment.
That's the type of boot that is made for that.
You know,
there's some synthetics out there too that,
that might dry a little easier in that.
But I've always been one where it's like,
you know,
I just,
I,
I don't have issues with blisters.
You know,
I,
I don't,
I just,
I'm just lucky that way.
I haven't ever had to deal with that.
When I wear a pair of my lightweight,
uh,
you know,
under Armour is my speed freaks or whatever and it's like I wore him,
I'm in my,
and halfway through my second season on one pair of boots,
which typically I go through a pair of boots easy in a season,
but this lightweight pair of speed freaks,
I've had it in the snow.
You know,
the shale,
this is under armor speeds and under Armour speech,
these ones are prototypes.
I don't know if it's the actual speed freak,
it's a prototype boot.
They sent me a new product that's kind of be cool.
That's awesome.
That's one cool thing about,
you know,
I've been on knocking on underarmour's door for three or four years and last
year I was fed up.
I was like,
you know what,
these guys are never going to give me the time of day.
They're cool guys and everything,
but they're looking for bigger fish.
And so this is probably the first time they've heard that is like I,
I got rid of all my under Armour gear and uh,
was decked out with another brand.
They decked me out everything,
head to toe,
everything.
So I was like,
I was all geared up to go on my first hunt in this other brand.
And uh,
then something just hit me.
My wife's like,
where'd you get all that Cam on?
Cause I told her the story and she's like,
what about under Armour?
And I go,
I can't give up on under Kanye.
And she's like,
you were going to give up on under Armour.
So I went to,
I was leaving for my hunt,
I went to shields and I bought a pair of pants and a shirt under Armour pair of
pants and a shirt.
I went on my hunt,
I killed this deer while I was driving back.
Coby gave me a call and said,
hey,
things have developed.
We've,
we've got some stuff freed up.
We'd really love to have you guys on board.
So it's like,
holy crap,
I just about threw underarmour way,
you know,
just from that.
But it,
but as a TV guys,
like you want to have the best brands,
you want to wear the guest best gear and everything.
But on the second part of it is you got to pay the bills.
You got to make it worth your while to do it.
Because at the end of the day,
I'm not doing it because I'm a passionate hunter.
I'm doing it because I'm a businessman.
I don't want to make a pile of money,
you know?
And it had just how it happens to be a sport that I love and I'm passionate
about and that's going to help me be a better business person.
And people don't know that under Armour does hunting gear.
They're huge in the hunting world.
People think of them as terms of other athletics.
Yeah.
Were there.
Just kidding me.
We just announced the coming soon have their new a ridge reaper,
Barron Barron Cammo pattern,
Remy and I,
and there's,
there's like six or eight of us nationwide that had these prototype clothings
and the war,
this cammo pattern.
Cameron's Cameron's got it as well and uh,
they just announced that it's going to be releasing it.
I heard the September 15th,
one of the dates was thrown out,
but they're going to be coming out with that,
uh,
at a underarmour.com.
The Ridge reaper line with the baron cammo pattern.
Pretty sweet.
Do you ever go out and realize that you fucked up?
You should have brought more shit always.
Really?
No.
Yeah.
That's happened.
And it's also gone the other way too where I've gotten there and I'm like,
why did I bring this mostly camera stuff?
I mean I pack around this five pound,
11,000 millimeter,
whatever it 1100 millimeter lens,
the weighs like six pounds.
I pack that sucker everywhere and I'd never use it.
And it's like,
why am I packing that thing and my spot and scope and all this?
It's like,
is there anything that you like when,
like if you haven't brought it with you,
like if you had gone out there and go,
God,
why didn't I bring this?
Is there anything like dangerous about that?
Have you ever taken,
if you ever like taken a trip and not having enough clothing or not having
enough?
Yeah.
Um,
survival shit.
I always have survival stuff with me.
I carry a survival medic.
It's just a little,
a super lightweight first aid kit,
but it has survival tools with it too,
you know?
So I have that in every,
I've got one in every backpack I use that's just there,
like start fires.
Thankfully I rarely have to use it,
you know?
And if I do use it,
it's just more just for fun to start a fire or something.
But it's there if I do need it.
Um,
I don't know what I've run into a situation where it's like,
man,
I wished I would have had this or that.
Um,
cause it's such,
yes.
Dot.
Yeah,
hunting.
So few people do that that way where you go completely on your own.
Well and I grew hunting with nothing.
You know,
I had a bow with piece of crap arrows and it was the cheapest thing we could
find and I hunted with that same boat.
The boat that I bought when I was 14 was the first,
I think all I have been 15 I bought that Bo.
I hunted with that until I was,
until I got into TV till 2004 it was a compound or a compound bow barely.
It was a Polaris,
a PSE Polaris that I bought that bow.
It was like $109 or something.
A hundred feet per second.
I don't know.
I don't know,
maybe who knows.
But I hunted with that thing and then I got back out of college.
I was talking with that thing and I got a hundred with that clear til 2004
before I got a Mathews bow and I'm like,
holy cow,
there's a,
there's a 12 year,
15 year span of time there that I hunted with a piece of crap.
And so I think that by me learning to get by with so little that it makes it
easier for me.
When I do have good equipment,
I can appreciate it that much more.
And it's like I can get by with just a good just good equipment.
The world of hunting gadgets,
compound bows is,
that's the oneworld where 10 years makes a giant leap.
Whereas like with rifles 10 years ago,
it's a rifle.
Scopes are a little better,
but rifles essentially a rifle,
bullets are bullets,
but the,
the bows of 10 years ago in comparison to the bowser today,
I mean they are making these little incremental leaps like every year where
they're getting a little bit lighter,
a little bit more feet per second,
a little bit more accurate,
a little bit better tolerance.
It's really kind of interesting to see the technology that's involved in
compound bows,
both for target shooting and for hunting.
And it's interesting that the bow company that I deal with with chief five and
prime is like g five is an engineering firm.
You know,
they're an engineering company.
So if anybody's going to know how to make something better and to get the most
out of a piece of iron,
it's an engineering company is somebody that has that background.
So that's what's really cool about them.
And these companies are smart.
They're not just going to just blow their wad on all our technology all at once.
They're going to incrementally bring it out so they can have a new bow every
year.
And that seems to be like the craze right now is every,
every bow manufacturer has one or two new bows every year.
And it's like,
man,
how,
how do you keep up with that?
Well how to keep up with technology.
But as a hunter,
I'm kind of addicted that it's like,
yeah,
I like this bow.
But in October,
as soon as that new prototype bow comes out,
I want it in my hand,
you know,
because we're addicted to that new,
bigger,
better,
badder just like the iPhone six,
you know,
mark was telling me about that and I'm like you were mocking the iPhone four.
Yeah I got an iPhone four you know,
you haven't even had a format for like forever.
He went crazy lens attachment that you put on your,
uh,
I've seen that too.
You put it on a spot and scope and you can film it.
Right.
What does that cause a phone scope adapter and I've just gotten used to having
it on my phone every once in while I'll take my phone out and put it back in my
life proof case.
But then I reached in my pocket.
I'm like,
where's my handle?
I'm missing my handle.
But this is just an adaptor.
It goes onto a bayonet mount,
a sleeve.
So I can slide it over my spotting scope or,
and you can zoom in,
you can video.
Yeah,
take pictures.
And what's cool is you shoot a little video clip or take a photo and Bam you to
Instagram,
Wham,
you're done.
And that kind of stuff.
So that's pretty cool.
So you take a photo from straight from the spotting scope.
Exactly,
yeah.
Does digital scoping with it.
And I just leave it in the case because you know my phone,
I just like having that handle.
It's just kinda convenient.
Yeah,
I love it because when I take it off I'm like missing it.
And it's not that I,
I don't use this phone scope other than when I'm hunting.
So it's like when you were talking for folks who don't know what you were
saying,
you were talking about ranging these laser range finders are another really cool
invention where you look into it,
you press a button,
it tells you the exact yardage.
And for people who've never been hunting with bows before,
it never shot a bow before.
They don't understand the,
like there's a big difference between a scope on a rifle.
A rifle is pretty good for a couple of hundred yards,
but a bow,
there's a big difference between where it's going to hit at 20 yards versus
where it's going to hit at 40 yards.
And all of this is sort of crazy calculations on feet per second and where your
yardage pins are and it's I,
that was one thing that I really got into when I started playing with Bose,
who's helped how much you have to learn,
like develop a site tape and you know,
and,
and the range things out and figure out like siting in your bow and making sure
everything's tuned up and it's,
there's,
there's so,
so many weird adjustments that you have to make between 20 and 50 yards and how
difficult it is to shoot something at 50 yards.
Yeah,
just a target.
You don't have a steady rest.
There are bi-pod like you do with a rifle.
I mean the bow you've got,
you've got your arm that's not very rigid to begin with holding it out there and
you've got your other arm back here and so you're trying to anchor it and no
magnification either.
No you can't.
There's,
there's some magnification scopes out there,
you know,
that you could put on there.
One or two power,
six power,
whatever.
I don't,
I'm so old school when it comes to my equipment,
I mean it's just like I'll take a bow and I set up all my own equipment.
I don't take it into the,
the archery shops because everybody has their own way of doing things.
But I do it the way I learned,
but I'll just put a peep sight,
you know,
cited in the guys are guys are all wrapped into these,
these super long range sites.
Well,
I'm a hunter so I need a site that's going to go from 20 to 80 you know,
and I'm good.
I don't need 120 a hundred Fishman,
these rolling single pane.
Be Fun to shoot that far,
but I don't if I want to shoot that far,
I go get my Moa rifle and I shoot that far.
You know it's like,
well I,
you know,
I learned from Cameron.
Cameron does all of his hunting with bows and arrows help and Cameron Hanes
never heard of him.
He uses a spot Hogg who you never heard of her camera NHANES.
You keep doing that shit joke.
You're going to have to let that go.
We're almost done here.
That's like my joke.
But um,
do you use multi Pinsight?
Yeah,
do for the longest time I just use a single pin site but once I started really
filming my bow hunts real heavily to just became too much to have to adjust that
pin.
So I just went to the multiple pin sites again so that I don't have any
adjustment on the bow.
I can focus on adjusting the camera.
When you said that you just cited in the animal,
you didn't
even cite it in,
you just just looked at it and you just take a an an estimate.
Is that something that just comes over time?
Like you look at something go,
that's about 30 yards until I was 25 years old,
I didn't use sites.
It was all instinctive.
So every,
every time I would shoot about his fingers and it was bare bow instinctive,
even though it was compound,
everything was instinctive.
And so I think it just ingrains into you if you're a traditional shooter or
whatever,
when you draw back your,
like your body,
just like shooting a pistol,
you know your body automatically gets into that position.
And more times than not,
if you'll,
if you'll draw back and get in that position and then look at your pins,
you're there.
You mean here if,
if you,
you've done it a lot in your condition to that and I think that's where your
instincts kind of take over.
And in those cases I drew back and I,
and I,
you just look at your pin,
verify Bam.
You know,
and you go,
so you're still aiming.
But because you're not thinking about it,
it's happening so much quicker.
They say that that's,
you know what,
some of the sharp shooters,
that's why they're so good is because it's just all instinctive with pistols or
anything else.
They're not aiming.
There's just shooting.
There's a lot of practice involved in bow hunting too,
right?
I,
I've had a boat.
I started bow hunting as the 1213 years old.
You know,
I have had,
I've had a bow in my hand my entire life.
Basically,
I'm just,
because of my upbringing,
I'd go out to do chores.
You grab your bow off of the freezer,
you walk out filling a couple arrows at the carpet target that we had taped onto
the haystack,
and you'd go milk the cows.
You walk out,
you pull your arrows,
you do it again.
It was lifestyle.
It's,
it's life for me growing up that way,
I shoot less now just because of the business of life and the other other
responsibilities I have.
But it's still,
it's still part of it and it's natural.
So for a guy picking it up,
for you to go out and,
and be able to experience that instinctive anchoring and everything is just
dialed,
it's going to come over time,
you know?
And there'll be times where you might go out next week and you're like,
man,
I know what he's talking about.
That feels good.
And then the next day you're gonna be like,
what the hell am I doing wrong?
This just isn't working.
And that's our tree.
That's,
that's the nature of your bow.
Your,
your,
your wrist is going to tweak.
Things are gonna change and from day to day.
So don't feel like you have to adjust your bow every time you go out and shoot.
Just be like,
Yup,
today I was pulling them left.
You know,
today I'm dropping them out.
No big deal.
Tomorrow will be a different,
you know.
Well,
that's the cool thing about archery is how difficult it is.
It's so,
it's so involved that it sort of takes away all the other things in your life
away.
It takes away all the other things you were thinking about,
all the other distractions in your mind.
You're so concentrating on putting that pin,
holding it steady,
making sure you release no,
no added movement,
no,
no twitching node polling.
And it's,
I find it like almost like meditative in that way.
And when I do it,
I,
it cleans my mind out.
I love doing it.
At the end of the day,
I have a busy day.
I go out in my yard,
I,
you know,
pull out some targets and start shooting.
And I feel like it's a nice stress reliever too.
Even if people never want to hunt.
I recommend a dude just doing archery just for fun and get a bowl and do it
instinctively.
You should get a recurve or get a bare boat and just go out and just do it
close,
you know,
10,
10 feet and just get that feeling of just release.
It helps your,
it helps.
It'll help your I so because I grew up that,
I mean that's,
that's how I did it.
And,
and you know,
to this day I think it's made me a better shooter in a hunting situation.
It's tricky to hunt with a bow because more animals get wounded and escape bow
hunting than probably any other style.
I don't know.
Yeah.
I don't know what this to take some and there's a lot of,
a lot of deer get hammered by a rifle to and walk away.
It's hard.
Sure.
It's hard to say.
There's just that many more rifle hunters out there.
Bows are tough because hemorrhaging is lethal.
You don't,
hemorrhaging is,
I mean you can shoot,
I shot a bear in the ankle one time,
you know,
when the wrist bled out with an 80 yards,
hemorrhaging is super lethal,
whereas a bullet,
it doesn't necessarily have to give you hemorrhaging.
It can give you puncture an impact and,
and shock and trauma.
But it doesn't necessarily hemorrhage not the same way because of the heat and
the cauterized and yeah,
it could,
could be.
So,
I don't know.
I can't,
can't say for sure.
Yeah.
I just had a,
I felt I had a massive responsibility to put it in a lot of practice for
everyone.
Bow Hunting and I mean it was,
I,
I fucked my shoulder up because I was shooting 150 hours hours a day.
Don't pull the Cameron Cameron Hanes is it,
don't pull the Cameron Hanes and shoot or 90 pound bow shoot a 70 pound.
All you need is 70 is that all you need?
I had a 1744 to five you know,
but do you,
because what have you hit a bone and then the animal runs away.
Cameron has this,
this philosophy about pat.
Well he never just the guy's philosophy,
you know,
and that's great.
And it works for him.
Sweet.
And I just knew Jen has the 45 pound philosophy,
whatever.
He's got a Ted Nugent's got his,
what do you shoot?
A 70 I shoot mine at like 63 pounds or something.
Yeah.
I mean I'm a,
I'm a strong guy.
I can pull up 70 80 pounds.
Sure.
But you choose to do the other one.
Yeah.
Just because it's more convenient.
More accurate.
I found that with my arrows and my broad heads and my set up,
I take my boat and I maxed to the 70 pounds.
And as I'm siting in and and,
and tuning my bow paper tuning or whatever,
I back it off a quarter turn at a time,
my limb.
So you're taking the weight down and I found that that 63 to 65 range for me and
my set up.
I'm getting bullets.
Yeah.
Cameron is like,
it does all these crazy workouts just so he could pull it effortlessly.
Yeah,
it's awesome.
But he's into like shooting water buffaloes and shit and yeah,
pass throughs on shine elks and that's his whole deal.
Uh,
listen man,
we're out of time.
Sweet.
That was three hours.
It's good cause I gotta take a leak.
I bet you do.
Go take it.
You got to get it was this great solar hunter Solo Hunter TV on Twitter.
What's your Instagram ads?
Solo hundred TV on Twitter,
Instagram and Facebook.
Everything.
The whole deal.
Timber Net.
Thank you very much.
Brian shares really enjoyable and watch the show.
It's on the outdoor channel.
It's called Solo Hunter is one of my favorite hunting shows.
It's really enjoyable show,
even if you don't like hunting,
it's very,
very well done.
Uh,
thank you to our sponsors.
Thank you.
To draft Canaan's Dotcom,
go to draft kings.com entering the Promo Code Rogan to play for free and become
a millionaire for real.
Um,
go to the website,
check it out.
[inaudible] you will be blown away.
It's amazing how much money you can make with fancy football these days.
Um,
what else we have today,
Ting Tang,
thanks to tango to rogan.ting.com.
Uh,
and save 25 bucks off of any ting device.
And thanks of course to onnit.com go to o n n I t and take part in human
optimization.
Use the Codeword Rogan and save 10% off any and all supplements we will be back.
Ladies and gentlemen,
next week I got Rupert Sheldrake,
Graham Hancock and others.
Until then,
enjoy your weekend.
See at the Ice House and a big kiss.